[Musique]
m
il
je
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
non
à
ok
[Musique]
et
je
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle compétition salut fans
c'est le calme salut à tous lang fab
nouvel après-midi sous le signe des
échecs et la nouvelle compétition dans
le calendrier international avec cette
nationscup la la coupe des nations
exactement que ma nouvelle compétition
qui va se passer avec six équipes
donc il y aura des nations il y aura des
sélections un peu de tout donc par le
nom un peu de ses sélections de ces
nations je sais qu'on va voir l'europe
avec un coq à sa tête exactement avec
maxime leader de l'équipe sera
accompagné donc de l'even à rognan anish
giri jan christoph schubert et de anna
amnésie tchouk et la nana benz est donc
ça ce sera l'équipe d'europe c'est
l'équipe bombe a prêché notre paroisse
on va les supporter fans puisque c'est
l'équipe qui a un joueur français et
puis finalement on est européen donc on
sera un petit peu partisan
voilà bah oui qui seront des adversaires
du coup alors l'autre sélection c'est la
sélection reste du monde donc c'est un
peu un les gens de partout donc tu auras
pierogi temps à radjabov tôt rabat scène
le jeune georges et cory du pérou et
épuisera l'autre soeur ni tchouk maria
cette fois et ça doit qu'à se voit donc
du kazakhstan 6 à doha cabaret way jouer
ce kazakh qui acquièrent et ailleurs été
entraînés par un illustre entraîneur
femmes puisqu'elles étaient coachés
pendant des années par un certain
vladislav quatre chefs un bien connu en
france voilà qui donne l'heure donc
forcément joueuses et bien et très
dangereux et très dangereuse qui sera
remplaçante dans la sélection des du
reste du monde
est-ce que mur tu as à votre grand
entraîneur mais là aussi rien de très
dangereux
maintenant c'est la titulariser contre
l'europe grand danger pour nous ça peut
faire mal et après l'onta quatre pays
qui vont jouer quatre gros pays bas très
fort chaque évidemment frikat la chine
la chine et quand les favoris de la
compétition que ce soit sur le papier ou
même toi tu me disais fab avant
près de l'antenne tu as peur des chinois
voilà ils ont l'air ils ont l'air très
fort parce que en fait du coup les
compos c'est quoi ces quatre joueurs
mixte et de filles est en fait en
féminisant la championne du monde actuel
et la numéro un mondiale donc où il fane
et idiot engine et largeur mixte manset
dingjian carrure autres mondiale wang
hao qui auront 12 mondial donc ces deux
joueurs-là sont aux candidats admis
aujourd'hui mon en gros on va dire tu as
aussi wii qui était un des plus jeunes
grands maîtres de l'histoire et le
zombie qui qui est actuellement 33e
joueur mondial mais qui était pas loin
du top 10 il ya quelques mois juste une
petite baisse de régime
donc c'est hyper compact hyper fort à
tous les étages juste pour rappeler un
petit peu les règles on va avoir trois
joueurs mixte aux trois premiers
échiquiers
donc on peut mettre deux filles
regardent enfin deux garçons il fit même
deux filles et un garçon en quoi un de
des échiquiers mixte les trois premiers
et le quatrième c'est un peu
l'obligation d'avoir une fille dans
l'équipe donc qu'enfin vous dis à six
joueurs il ya 4 mixte quatre hommes en
fait dans toutes les équipes il se
trouve que 4 4 hommes pour un peu
simplifié mais c'est mixte il pourrait y
avoir autant de filles qui le souhaitent
et une fille obligatoire au quatrième
avec une remplaçante donc si jamais il y
avait un problème ou si le l'entraîneur
de la sélection décidé de changer de
joueur il aurait de remplaçant à sa
disposition d'ailleurs t'as oublié de
nous dire je le précise que c'est garry
kasparov 1 que tout le monde connaît qui
sera fabien le cpe- inquiète le
sélectionneur de l'équipe d'europe qui
selon à quel rôle bah je pense qu'il va
avoir le rôle de dégager ceux qui jouent
mal
ben tu vois je sens pas kasparov un
sélectionneur compréhensif et 10
secondes tu as déjà perdu deux parties
je te laisse jouer une troisième pour te
relance les lens n'en oublie cette
compétition peut-être l'an prochain mais
d'ailleurs non l'an prochain non plus je
ne te reconnais que jamais après bon a
notifié 0 sur 4
je suis obligé de reprendre ce joueur
qui était très nul avant mais je ne vais
pas leur lancer bureau ici on était très
nul probablement
réussir à rien peut-être car arrive à
jouer lui-même y aller mais ça joue seul
seul contre tous et à nous pour faire le
tour des autres équipes mais aussi les
usa y aura l'inde et la russie
donc nous on va commencer des contrôles
un but l'intérieur voilà donc la russie
alors je sais pas quelle équipe ils vont
mettre pour le premier match parce que
votre eau
enfin le pôle d'enseignement on va
savoir les compos 30 minutes avant
chaque match il doit pas donner ça aussi
c'est mort mais donc leur liste de six
joueurs c'est bien des pommiers tchimou
en 4 mondial il ya carrier clean donc
bien connu il était finaliste du
championnat du monde luc 16,1 artemiev
qui est là il rendre équine aussi donc
ça c'est des joueurs dans le top 30
mondial solide et gorillaz qui n'a fait
mine d'en but en 3 mondial et finaliste
machine est ok a failli qui a failli
gagner le match contre joue ajoute
d'ailleurs insiste un match très dur un
crochet qui s'est jouée au départage
donc elle est extrêmement forte et en
remplaçant une remplaçante ces guérillas
google
mon prénom galharet mais qui est quand
même là on il faut dire que pour
l'échiquier féminin de la russie gary h
quine à ça se peut qu'elle joue tous les
matches parce que c'est une machine bah
mon avis toute façon si tu trouves ton
équipe qui ne t'a pas de tourner pour
tourner alors femme avant d'aller plus
loin j'aimerais bien parler un petit peu
de comment se déroulent les matches
vas-y donc on a notre petit bandeau donc
les participants six équipes invitées tu
viens de les citer donc tous et 1 tout
rond d'allers-retours donc toutes les
équipes se joueront deux fois joueront
deux matches différents les unes contre
les autres en cas de victoire deux
points match nul un point défaite zéro
point les deux premières équipes à
l'issue des dix rondes sont qualifiés
donc pour la super finale qui aura lieu
dimanche
exact là ce sera le feu d'artifice en
cas d'égalité
donc dans le dans la phase de groupe
l'équipe ayant terminé première de la
phase de poules est déclaré vainqueur de
la coupe des nations c'est pour la
finale en cas de match nul
celui qui a fini premier en
du championnat gagne la compétition donc
ça va être un énorme avantage fat de de
remporter la phase de poules 1 ça
donnera un énorme avantage sur quatre
échiquier match nul entre deux grosses
équipes est quand même assez logique
cadence donc ça c'est le temps que les
joueurs auront pour jouer la partie 25
minutes pour toutes leurs parties un
rajout à chaque fois qu'ils jouent de 10
secondes par tous donc c'est à peu près
30 minutes chacun globalement way et les
équipes voilà chaque équipe est
constituée de quatre titulaires 3 alors
il me trois hommes et une femme mais bon
3 mixte et une femme et deux remplaçants
à
et un capitaine donc fab
on va pouvoir petit à petit se diriger
vers la compétition donc on a les
échiquiers alors les équipes on n'a pas
le bon match mais on va récupérer
réussir à avoir le bon match alors j'ai
pas encore je deviens l'allaitement côté
1 mais on va encore me des gènes alors
et on va se mettre en ouvre le score
d'europe réussi on va choisir europe
russie comme match phare note sur la
glace le plu sera prête et on fera un
petit tour des stades
si c'est bien avancé ou quoi il n'aura
surtout se focaliser là dessus
ouais pas se focaliser là dessus et on
va se focaliser à la caméra sur le
numéro un européen dans cette
compétition numéro un français fab
maxime vachier lagrave exactement bat
maxime qu'on connaît bien qui nuiront 5
mondial qui a déjà été mis hors d'eux et
qui est de loin le meilleur joueur
français de 7 en ce moment qui a très
bien réussi au tour des deux candidats
qui en tête mi parcours est un des tout
meilleurs jean-rougeau pas simplement
qu'ils se recadrent bien à la caméra il
sait tout faire maxime forme très bon
cadrage
c'est un athlète il pourrait être
cameraman pour une pour une prochaine
compétition car il sait tout faire
voilà on a l'habitude de le voir sur la
chaîne on connaît bien maxime il est
concentré il a un petit peu raté le manu
s'invite à fiona alain-fabien ça ça peut
être ça peut être un peu un peu
inquiétant mais mais on est sûr qu'il
voudra porter haut les couleurs de
l'europe
ouais bien plus
lamonde la galerie qui veut souffler
dans les bronches si ça se passe mal
donc il faut être au taquet il le sera
il le sera femme on a juste désolé un
petit problème comme vous voyez sur les
compos à gauche on a un problème sur les
compos à vos attentes peut-être que je
vais ok c'est en fait je vais les avoir
ici fab on va prendre les bonnes équipes
et voilà les compos qui sont arrivés fab
avec une composition match de rêve quand
même
yann nepomniachi maxime vachier lagrave
on dit envie de te dire tombe on ne
rentre même pas tu vas tu est tellement
il est fort son nom de rente même pas tu
as un beau mariage qui n'a comme car
elle avait des gens qui sont un peu au
dessus le monde rentre pas mais
nepomniachi vachier lagrave c'est les
deux leaders des candidats en tournoi
qui est le mieux s'arrêter en plein
milieu donc c'est peut-être quelque part
symboliquement numéro deux et trois
mondial
un deuxième échec et elle est bonne à
royal ça fait plaisir de le revoir à la
compétition après la tragédie qui lui
arrive et sa femme qu'elle écoute où
nous adore ça ça le mieux pour lui quoi
ça me fait plaisir de le revoir sur un
échiquier vraiment et j'espère qu'il
pourra bien joué ça rendra un genre
d'hommage quoi peut-être et donc il sera
opposé à artemiev donc jeune joueur
russe une petite vingtaine d'années qui
montrent bien et très dangereux sur
internet en plus en 2d sur les skis en
2d très fort d'alprech mentionné rare
parce que tommy haas il joue pour les
états unis ou qui peut pas être le cas
team europe oui une erreur mais ça doit
probablement être vianne christophe tout
d'abord vous confirmera sa joueur
polonais très doux et très fort en
cadence rapide ouais très très bon il a
été je crois vice champion - médaille de
bronze en plein d'humour de rapide il ya
deux ans oui donc ainsi une de ses
spécialités
mais andré qui d'en face il va payer
pour leurs gardiens landry keane qui
devrait donc lui est moins en moins pro
il voit une vie de famille il a été père
de famille il a moins les stylistes de
temps sur les échecs à fond mais s'en
cache pas que ce soit de 30 mondial
quand même ça
républicain il est vraiment fort et
surtout en rapide paris c'est une
cadence qui nous dans lequel il excelle
et 4e échiquier alexandra gary h qui va
on en a parlé
finaliste du championnat du monde très
forte mentalement très très solide fab
c'est même une défaite ça fait pas trop
tremblé là de la partie il fait montre
c'est une machine c'est vraiment une
machine extrêmement forte mais anna
bouzid chou qui a été championne du
monde un fab
non mais en plus elle n'est pas largué
toujours numéro 7 mondial ouais donc ça
va être ça va être très tendu c'est
c'est vraiment difficile de donner un
favori sur ce match peut-être peut-être
l'équipe d'europe avec un doux dingue
troisième un peu plus fort qu andré
qu'il mais bon y'a le quatrième avec
mariage qui n'a sinon les deux premiers
échiquiers c'est du 50-50 face et qui
utilise exactement donc beau match en
perspective
on va être belle compo et écoute je
pense que pendant qu'on en parle et ça a
dû commencer vous ça a dû être en train
de commencer je vais aller essayer de
choper les échiquiers que je ne vois pas
pour le moment
donc ça n'a pas encore commencé à mon
avis tous les joueurs sont en ligne ça
va partir d'une seconde à l'autre ça
c'est sûr maxime qui a l'air bien
concentré 1
il faut pour nos échoppes équipes
d'europe qui sera emmenée par un coq
comme ceux qui mangent un petit peu qui
s'alimentent avant la partie il ya il ya
de l'enjeu favin dès le début il n'y
aura pas beaucoup de matches a que 10
matches il faut finir dans les deux
premiers
il faudra en gagner à mon avis a minima
cette affaire sept points probablement
et en plus derrière après ce match on va
se coltiner la chine
c'est vrai donc les favoris comme on
lisait la chine a une grosse grosse
équipe et web en photo en galice premier
match déjà pour aborder le seconde
la commission pas t'imaginer le niveau
de la compétition quoi tu dis ouais je
vous la russie ça va ça va je suis
encore te prendre la chine les etats
unis l'inde aussi un don on a maintenant
on parle non mais lundi seront homogènes
avec il ya un an d'un autre ancien
champion du monde
il sera sûrement assez motivé il y avait
dit très à l'aise sur internet
harry krishna qui est très bien
l'embellie qui j'ai pu même niveau
joueuses il on connait roule acquis qui
est forte à qui nous avons demandé à
lancement oui donc ils ont une belle
équipe ils vont être motivés je pense
avec un esprit l'équipe et donc les usa
appareils grosse équipe juste peut-être
point faible je n'ai au delà des
joueuses parce que ce soit irina crash
ou anna j'attends ce qui l ont elles
autour de 1420 donc crush la mieux
classée des deux et numéro 36 mondiale
les a transcrits durant 46 donc c'est
pas non plus le top 10 mondial par
rapport à toutes les autres sélections
va donc y aura une petite fragilité sur
sur le 4e 4e échiquier exactement des
usa mais par contre le 1 et le 2 avec
nakhla murat et à écart au juana ça fait
quand même très peur
caruana qui est qui était finaliste du
championnat du monde contre carl scène
il ya maintenant deux ans qui est numéro
deux mondial et nakamura sur internet
c'est c'est l'un des tous meilleurs 1
donc ils vont faire très très mal de
vent ouais
puis après que ce soit dominguez très
bon en rapide ou est ce les sauts pareil
donc oui ils sont ils sont très forts
devant mais donc et fragilité au 4ème
échiquier et c'est ça qui me fait mettre
la chine un peu devant eux qui sont
aussi très fort donc mais pour le coup
parce tragédie dos 4e et chic et c'est
sûr qu'il ya tellement peu d'échecs si
tu mets deux points aux 4 il reste 3
devant en sachant qu aux échecs là nul
reste quand même le résultat le plus
logique et d'irène nakamura ces séries
de chez serré fabiano caruana wang hao
c'est en plus un mauvais match up pour
pour fabiano qui a un peu de mal face à
ce joueur chinois qui a pas de supers
résultats donc le lundi 1 et un peu pas
vraiment pas si avantageuse que ça aux
états unis alors après peut-être au31
wesley so qui peut quand même fab mettre
une pression sur wii si on regarde si on
regarde les matchs entre ces deux
équipes favorites mais bon ça se jouera
dans un mouchoir de poche 1 toute façon
mais sûrement et pour nous pour pour
l'équipe d'europe la grosse question
sera bien évidemment ce deuxième
échiquier dont on a parlé ensemble avec
avec levon les bonnes aronian comment il
se serait il s'est mis de sa situation
personnelle très compliqué on verra
c'est une bonne question c'est un tel
drame dans sa vie que tu as beau avoir
la solidité mentale que tu veux personne
n'est préparé à ça non heureusement
d'ailleurs qu'on ne se perd pas ce genre
de tragédie parce que sinon ce serait
compliqué sinon ce serait compliqué
s'ils me concentrer en tout cas prêt à
en découdre
15h05 1 doit y avoir j'imagine des
annonces officielles un genre de petite
cérémonie d'ouverture avant de lancer le
coup d'envoi ballet ont commencé
bouger d'un coup d'envoi donc ces dépôts
avec les blancs dont je crois que c'est
europe pour réussi donc c'est vrai ouais
alors qu'ils sont pas gouré à gauche
avec les couleurs s'en va je vois pas
les parties annoncé sur aucun site n'est
pas là on n'y a pas de plus vient on va
découvrir en même temps que vous mais le
match et 107 europe russie donc d'un
mois aura plus les coups de c à c et 20
c
mbi style à des blancs maxime alors
atteint il faut que je le trouve à
laisser partir et c'est bien maxime qui
a les blancs et police fighters et duda
au troisième et chic et contrant
drinking d'accord et voilà je propose
qu'on ouvre un petit peu les échiquiers
puis on regardera la partie de maxime
qu'on va bien expliqué on va juste
ouvrir toutes les parties pour les avoir
et on va se concentrer sur la partie de
maxime alors on va revenir au début 4 c
5 fab ouverture sicilienne donc c'est
l'ouverture fétiche de yann nepomniachi
qui avait tout de même joué la française
que ce soit aux candidats puis après on
m'accuse de celle originale exactement
mais ça s'était mal passé contre maxime
déjà avait perdu aux candidats et aux
magnus peut-être que les faits il est
sauvé mais il était très bon en tout cas
fabien on disait avec maxime que j'avais
eue en interview que dépôts allait
peut-être revenir à un âge d'or comme
lorsque les compétitions officielles
reprendront un qui changera de son fusil
d'épaulé et c'est vrai que là c'est une
première compétition officielle sur
internet puisqu'elle est sous l'égide de
la fidh nepomniachi qui joue pour sa
patrie et on sait que pour les russes
défendent le drapeau c'est quelque chose
d'important et il retourne sur la nage
d'arc donc pas de surprise un finalement
ils prennent la compétition au sérieux
exactement et puis et puis même maxime
qui a joué 80 du coût plus d'aisé avec
des dégâts pourquoi alors c'est sûr
qu'avec gary entraîneur je vais dire si
tu continues à faire des quatre
d'écouter ses choix il va ouais mais bon
garry kasparov c'est pas marrant
non il n'a pas cette réputation là et
donc fou détroit un coup assez rare par
contre un but de maxime exposition qui
reprend un peu une idée que alexander
guichou qui avait joué mais avec une
petite différence donc cavalier b17 rock
et j'ai dit ça on va faire un petit
arrêt sur cette position fab est ce que
tu peux nous nous expliquer alors
attends je vais vraiment mettre la
position du direct le plus longtemps
possible et que nous explique un peu les
voilà on va se mettre là les tenants et
les aboutissants des deux camps quels
sont les idées des deux joueurs dans
cette ouverture
alors écoute c'est donc une bonne
diversion sicilienne les nord ils ont
placé leurs fous de gaz rares anciens de
kétou donc ces luttes
là ça va permettre de roque et d'être
assez solide et d'arad se joue sur une
grande diagonale et avoir un grand rayon
d'action
donc globalement les noirs je pense
qu'ils vont jouer avec p 5
le pion à nesle dames le chouan 17 donc
les deux chaussures le camp de diagonale
la tour sur la colonne en c8 et essayer
de mettre le centre blanc suppressions
d'emplois qu'elle n'en fait on pas
occuper le centre au dessus mais place
des pièces pour y faire pression dessus
donc c'est vrai que c'est entre
guillemets une stratégie qui n'est pas
forcément classique clasico échec
puisque les noirs ont donné le sens trop
blanc sert les blancs contrôle le centre
et ils contrôlent plus des espaces sur
l'échiquier l'on s'est rendu compte fab
avec l'expérience que ça pouvait être
intéressant de laisser le territoire
pour le contre attaquer c'est ce qui est
en train de faire yan lespoux minatchy
c'est ça mais en gros un contenu qu'on
peut vous donner ces deux quand même
toujours des pièces qu'ils fassent
action sur le centre berkman vous
l'occupez pas que des pions au moins
présents ici c'est important ça va
donner une grande liberté de manoeuvre à
vos pièces et est donc plus de facilité
à les faire jouer ensemble hi juste une
petite précision on vous le voyez à
gauche qui a une
à gauche de l'échiquier qu'il ya une
bas-rhin et ça représente l'évaluation
de l'ordinateur donc puis à de noirs
plus l'ordinateur préfère les noirs plus
à deux blancs puis préfère les blancs
tant que ça touche pas une
alors là je vais faire des flèches tant
que ça touche pas c'est ces zones là il
n'y a rien de très grave vous voyez là
par le milieu de la barre entre la 4e et
la 5e branger et vous voyez pour le
moment en début de partie que
l'ordinateur il évalue toujours entre
ces noms dans cette zone là et
finalement ces ordinateurs fabre même
s'ils sont plus fort que nous tant que
sa raison cette zone là il ya quand même
une zone d'erreurs donc il ya rien de
décisif
non non complètement ayem décisif 2 2
même si l'ordinateur voit des choses des
choix non le voit pas en tant qu'humain
et puis enfin l'ordinateur à droite se
tromper comme quelquefois il a le droit
d'avoir
on voit à la caméra fabing maxime maxime
concentré 1
on voit que ça paie peut-être convaincu
ses cheveux passé il est de retour
alors ils sont ils en train de se
demander avec quoi il reprend le cheval
et l'a décidé de le reprendre du pillon
et il se crée un centre vraiment
puissants qui pourraient faire avancer
en d 4 5 et ai commencé comme ça on dit
c'est que c'est une montagne ont souvent
dit c'est le pour les débutants que ces
cadeaux je m en rouge écoute que ça
c'était la montagne des échecs et ça
c'était la colline pour un peu avoir une
vision de l'échiquier parce que
lorsqu'on prend 3 le cetc case on va
plus loin et la maxime qui pourrait
marcher sur la colline adverse sur le
mental ou carrément quand il touche le
sommeil mam arbustes qui reste bien s'il
réalise ses pouces et puis on va comme
suit avec les flèches c'est que ça en ta
vraie complètement le foot cases noires
ménard car à une portée très limitée du
coup pour l'instant il est super ces
cavaliers bourgeois y rayonne et si tu
te prends des pions de lancer très bien
bougé après par contre évidemment
à noter qu'une forte parmi les options
là on peut plus reculer et ça pourrait
faire rayonner l'autre ou s'ils vont
baisser donc après toujours des chèques
des fois tu donnes quelque chose pour
enfin tu gagnes quelque chose mais il
faut savoir donner aussi donc faut
trouver le bon
les mois alors attention favand plus
parce que lorsque ce fou est en baisse à
être gars qui est-il en ligne de mire
j'habite way le pape il ya beaucoup de
pièces encore qui le séparant de mettre
un échec mais quand même ça peut ça peut
être désagréable avec tant que les pions
sont des trois ou quatre et un petit mur
c'est solide ça tient le pion détroit
protège 4 le fourbe et 7 peut pas
vraiment rayonner comme tu le disais à
voir est ce qu'on décide de d'enfermer
le fougueux bessette ou est ce qu'on
décide d'en fermer le fou g7 c'est la
question à laquelle devra répondre
maxime nous on est tranquille
fab on regarde bah oui on est épouse
n'ont d'autres idées pour les blancs
dans quel avec son âne écoute dames
c'est donc de lier les tours donc pour
aller placer sur les colonnes tout il
veut et qu'elle se défende l'une l'autre
mais en plus peut-être à un moment de
jouer la poussée f5
mais pour les deux camps donc les deux
joueurs peuvent voir les blancs peuvent
vouloir jouer f5 peut-être allait
s'emparer du fou g7 le savez bien le roi
de perse et les noirs pareil pour casser
ce mur blanc centre donc les deux fois
aurait l'idée de mettre que le premier
qui met le pion à f/5 pourrait prendre
l'aventage au final voilà la condition
soit fait dans les bonnes conditions
mais oui c'est intéressant et du cou
est-ce que c'est pas les blancs
finalement qu'ils vont réussir à le
faire en premier fable parce que les
plantes pourrait jouer f5 alors que les
noirs pour le moment le cavaly qui
obstruent donc si je perds vanité 7 pour
jouer cinq on aurait eu le temps de
fermer sa g briller il exactement
est ce que ça peut aller vite parce que
si on échange ce chou devant le roi
qu'on a beaucoup de chiens de pied toit
sans même un bon protecteur et ça peut
mal se passer
je montre un scénario possible avec un
matt qui arriverait angers7
bon là on a bien sûr été complaisante et
des les blancs a réalisé ce scénario
mais c'est un truc à surveiller pour la
voir oui mais on doit bien être un petit
peu complaisant pour montrer les idées
façon mais tu as bien raison de le
souligner fab four g4 alors les gammes
nepomniachi qui change son fils épaules
avec ce fou et qui par l'autre côté du
coup bon en tout cas c'est un truc
normal parce qu'il se développe donc on
dit toujours de chaix très important
développé les pièces pour que tous
joe et toutes les pièces soient actives
si vous jouez que sur un coin de
l'échiquier toit de l'armée n'est pas là
et c'est rarement efficaces comme bon
goût comme dans les jeux de comment les
autres jeux de stratégie 10 portes fab
ou si tu cites envoie deux trois unités
face à 40 unités adverses à sa part et
grand-chose mobilité soit très très très
forte
quand on voit des hulk est bon tu vas
faire mal mais pas sur tes débuts tout
tout le temps non plus et ouais donc bah
ça va permettre à la tour à leur entrée
sur la colonne là-bas et peut-être qu'il
ya de dépôt minatchy va décider de
d'échangés sochaux en fait part demain
soir vous comme h3 pour attaquer tout ce
mois là soit tu les changes voiture
repart mais si tu les changes par
exemple il y aura deux intérêt pour
l'inde en croquer squash 3 c'est que la
tour pourra pas prendre la place de ce
plan pour aller attaquer le long de la
colonne h un jour peut-être d'accord
donc le tueur obstrué une attaque avec
avec toutes les pièces blanches sur la
colonne h
voilà déjà et de deux ça va enlever le
cavalier qui aura été une pièce d'attac
quand on voit notre scénario tout à
l'heure il aurait pu rejoindre la dame
le fou en danger 5 d'accord donc ce
cavalier donc qui aurait pu venir verger
cinq plus tard pour aller jouer de
concert avec une dame par exemple voir
et long terme
exactement donc du coup de faire
disparaître ce cavalier pourquoi pas ça
peut être ça l'idée de haut niveau donc
maxime maxime qui se reconcentre et qui
calcule la à fond alors on voit alors
qu'elles sont et c'est ce que pousser
les pions au centre serait une option en
se disant vu que le fou ne peut plus
jouer sur cette diagonale
bah du coup j'essaye de faire mais lui
alors qu'est ce que les noirs peut faire
peut-être pions tranche bien et après
qu'elle valait qui mirent au centre en
d5 est ce que j'aime pas dans cette
situation c'est qu'on a beaucoup exposé
nokia clément et puis on des trois font
maintenant des quatre îles et arrière et
c'est à dire qu'en fait il a plus de
pions derrière lui pour le soutenir et
il est sur une colonne où les normes
voir mettre toutes leurs questions car
la dame les toux etc ont ramené beaucoup
de matériel pour la baguette et 2 2 on a
mis tous nos clients sur cases noires et
on a plus de chou pour couvrir ses cases
on a donné très envie plan
enfin les pions font un double emploi
avec le fouet le fou
des normes va pouvoir rayonner et régner
en maître sur les cases blanches
c'est ça donc on trouvera des manoeuvres
pour le recycler soit comme tu l'a mis
là soit par derrière la dame pour faire
une batterie et viser le roi met donc je
vois mal après les blancs comme on
pourrait avancer là dedans il faudra une
pièce pour bouger cette dame du centre
et continue à avancer les pions et là je
crois qu'on serait un peu bloqués côté
blanc alors ça me semble trop rapide en
fait de jeu d'accord donc maxime qui a
joué cavalier des quatre fables donc qui
ceux qui se laissent pas échangé qui se
met sur une case centrale qui va
peut-être chatouiller la case c6 pour
attac éventuellement la d'alain avoir ça
pourrait être une option peut-être aussi
aidé le coup f5 et enfermé le fou
regarde un scénario incroyable qui
pourrait arriver dont je fais jouer des
coûts inutiles au noir mais avec un fou
qui pourraient se retrouver embourbée
dans les pions blancs et qui n'aurait
plus de casse de repli est exactement le
signaler ça peut être une idée pour
aller blanc complètement donc ce qu elle
qui est partie on peut plus le plus
l'échangé et des petites menaces donc
maxime qui joue un coup un peu venimeux
fab 4 l air de rien en fait ils créent
des lits créés des menaces et on va voir
que ce que nepomniachi réussi à lui
opposer en tout cas il a l'air vraiment
dans sa partie maxime il n'a pas encore
relâché ma concentration intervet a
remarqué n'y a pas eu encore une seconde
de répit même si sa l'adversaire de
jouer maxime qui est qui est extrêmement
concentré sur le jeu et ils sont
adversaires qu'il réponde dalle 17 du
coup ok donc lille et tours est bon tout
est bien jours déjà dans le grand noir
et il pourrait y avoir une nulle rapide
fab éventuellement peut-être après h3
fou prend qui on prend dame prend h3
avec un échec perpétuelle si la dame
vient couvrir le four disparaîtrait
voilà donc la mauvaise opération pour
les blancs ça se passerait comme ça
parce qu'on a perdu les deux pions
devant droit de plonger h
et on a réglé un fou chacun dans
l'histoire depuis onze mois pour les
blancs et catastrophe mais d'ailleurs
m'a pas un noir très bas dans ce cas de
figure je laisse un peu ce que gt gt a
party will à la barre noire je vous
avais rien que vers le 3 ça commence à
être grave là quand ça s'approche du 1
c'est la gastro feu d'un paraît bien se
passer donc croisiens serez forcé pour
maintenir la protection et on pourrait
jouer éventuellement d'alger 3 watts un
terme à trois rois bien et ce serait une
partie nulle part ce qu'on appelle échec
perpétuelle puisque les blancs ne
pourrait pas sortir de l'échec et
larbitre accorderait la nul sinon la
partie pourrait durer indéfiniment
exactement donc c'est une option bien
sûr mais à mon avis maxime va essayer
d'être un peu plus ambitieux que ça
parce que normalement aux échecs quand
on a les blancs on essaie de mettre un
petit peu à sa suppression
c'est un peu comme jouer à domicile aux
shoots quelque chose comme ça on va dire
normalement tu essayes un peu on va voir
on va voir comment est ce qui peut jouer
ce f 5 1 il avait cette idée de faire f5
fab
ouais je demande à nos demandes parce
qu'ils menaceraient le h3 il couperait
la connexion de l'adar avec la case h3
et il y aurait plus l'histoire
sacrifices et appuyer sur un sacrifice
et y aurait de nouveau le l'histoire
d'enfermement est-ce que tu avais 10 h 5
2 6 4
alors pour venir par anticipation titi
alors la thur on est dans un cas de
figure justement on en parle avant n'est
pas content du tout on n'a pas les coûts
de l'ordinateur on ne connaît pas le bon
coup pour les blancs mais c'est vrai
qu'avec cette barre on comprend qui a un
coût et un cookie q faut-il encore le
voir et nous on voit par exemple mais
peut-être h300 bizarre tu laisses la
casse g3 congrès à lille mais au moins
tu dois en faire une foule mes parents
moi je pensais que ça allait pour les
noirs mais
ça semble aller à l'ordinateur je dis ok
on va perdre le fou mais en a quand même
pris un tour au passage et en a on va
dire et quand même la structure pions
des blancs absente des pions sur la
route et donc voilà qu'elle h50 fléchir
alors on peut on peut comme c'est du
rapide fab se trouver la réponse on en a
on a une petite aide pour pas passer
pour des idiots trop longtemps
l'ordinateur nous dit cavaliers des cinq
qui menacent de venir en b 6 pour faire
une fourchette haute c'est chiant c'est
vrai que c'est très pénible admettons
tour des huit pour se développer et
maintenant simplement tours fc 1 et vous
pourrez être la main le long de la
colonne sait et on aurait la menace
h3 puisqu'il y aurait plus de fourchette
avec le cavalier noir
donc voilà la réponse mais ça faut-il
encore le voir et maxime qui envoie f5
écoute il a eu le même salaire logique
ah oui tu crées une menace directe tu
menaces a je crois dans ferme il faut
donc là il ya une épopée achi doit
répondre à la menace 1 il faut trop mais
c'est package cinq en tout cas et c'est
pas cavalier abstraite mais ça il ya le
dépôt gâchis tu vois si si le voyais pas
y sera notre place pour pour commander
vos commentaires nous sommes en train
jaune
terreïs h5 je n'y ai même pas pensé
on nous propose eu 5 pour les noirs mais
e5 ça permettrait peut-être la prise en
passant donc ça compte un pion avance de
deux cases on peut l'intercepter au coup
suivant par une prise en passant mais
c'est maintenant j'avais laissé là n'ont
jamais puis on prend et moi j'aime pas
trop pour les noirs je sais pas je pense
que toi tu en pense on voit que la part
est pas gravissime dans un jeu jouable
mais moi je dirais plutôt pas une bonne
opération pour les ventes
parce qu'on sera ouvert le fou de trois
et on aurait un petit peu affaibli la
position dure 2 du roi adverse
ouais non ça c'est puis ça crée des îles
autres qui ont mes remarques pour les
blancs aussi mais je sais pas il ya
quelque chose qui me chiffonne dans
cette structure allait quelque quelque
chose qui ne paraît pas à monieux chez
les noirs non mais par contre ce qui est
possible donc sur scorff 5 ce serait de
réagir peut être par des cinq à la f5
pour les blancs c'est la position de la
partie ce serait jouer des 5
pour venir à miner le centaure qui a eu
un coup joué fab on va retourner sur le
dirais que là on était en analyse sur f5
il a à jouer eux 5 justement un il ya
peu de prison doit pas être prise en
passant il ya eu cavaliers c2 et des
cinq maintenant ok alors attention aux
menaces des noirs c'est de repousser
encore le pion en d4 au coup d'après
quitterie de fourche attaque le cabellou
oui donc faire attention avec les blancs
donc besoin ont vite compliqué parce que
à la fois les blancs ou rappellent ils
menacent le théâtre de verdure
h3 pour enfermer le foulard qui a plus
de caisses de retraite qui va battre en
cinq ans n'aura bougé 4 et et puissance
infinie jour qui sera soutenue par le
pion à 3 donc ça c'est la masse des
blancs mais en même temps les noirs
frappe au centre et menace aussi de
pousser et aussi de disloquer
complètement ses pions blancs qui était
présente depuis le début pour un peu
bloqué là la position noir alors fab on
va rempli de rentrer dans ce qu'on
appelle la phase tactique de la partie
en toutes les considérations
stratégiques dont on a parlé elle existe
bel et bien mais là c'est celui qui
frappe le premier 1 c'est c'est un
combat d'escrimé celui qui met la
première touche à gagner j'ai envie de
tenir fab ou alors ça touche en même
temps match nul mais admet ya plus de il
ya plus de petites de petites idées oui
je fais si j'ai cette idée je ferme ton
ful à cesser la guerre voilà c'est le
jeu qu'on craint c'est la guerre ils
vont l'avoir très bonne idée long terme
si ça marche pas c'est un choix et c'est
bien sa fable la différence entre entre
les joueurs de ce niveau du calibre
qu'on est en train de regarder et des
joueurs de notre niveau
ah oui bon même en stratégies sont très
bien mais un niveau calcule sa vitesse
de la lumière comme dans leur tête ouais
c'est vraiment là qu'on voit la
différence de niveau entre entre des
joueurs comme comme fabien qui a été
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france et
qui est un excellent grand maître et
combien tu es dans le top-30 français
top 20 non je crois qu'on tape un
français mais par rapport au numéro 1 2
3 c'est vraiment cette vitesse de calcul
qui va faire la différence
baru est complètement je sais pas quoi
leur dire que
d'autres 600e 700e quoi m en tape tout
plein de membres devant et eux ils sont
tous les deux nouveaux 4 et 5 mondiaux
donc c'est une autre c'est notre galaxie
dont qui jouent des 4 et j'imagine fable
comme on parle de ses tactiques on
aimerait bien faire [ __ ] wife 6 pour
partir vers des 5,1 supprimer le
protecteur de la case mais quand on vous
parle de celui qui touche en premier la
le pion viendrait prendre et toucherait
la dame est donc on resterait avec un
fou en prise en fin de variantes
même si c'est peut-être encore jouable
avec des enfermements de fou g4 mais ce
serait pas le scénario qu'on
rechercherait en première vue femmes non
en votre nom je pense qu'il va
simplement levé son cavalier mais
évidemment tôt bien avant de signaler on
a adoré et changer ce cavalier noir et
venir cette belle case au centre on le
rappelle un cavalier au centre de
l'échiquier c'est là où j'ai le mieux
parce qu'il touche lui case autour de
lui c'est une sorte de cercle s'étend
depuis alors quoi ce canal et et
d'apulée centrale puis va toucher des
cases intéressant alors que la 1e 2 il
est y est englué dans les pionts
regarder les cases que contrôle le
cavalier en avant sur trois des quatre
cases et bien il pour il n'y a pas accès
parce que les pions le bloc il est
englué dans les dents les pions et et
l'autre aussi en c2 d'arrêt un petit peu
englué donc il ya deux cavaliers anglais
mais il ya un karayan f6 qui pourrait
être sous danger côté noir il ya un fou
ici après cavaillé g3 ayache 3 qui
pourrait être enfermé la fable on est
dans une position vraiment très complexe
exactement là c'est là tout se joue on
va dire pour la suite et le cas les c2
alors ils peur un passage pour revenir
vers le centre via b4 et pour revenir
après vers des salons qui l'est moins en
bus et que l'autre voilà c'est plutôt
qu'à eux deux qui sait mais elle n'a pas
un grand avenir pour l'instant alors
après un cavalier on peut le manoeuvrer
et peut-être un jour il fera des
merveilles 1 mais pour l'instant on a en
effet le passif on a vu maxime à la
caméra s'alimenter un petit peu fabien
jus de fruits j'imagine jus de pomme
connaissant loustics ces apports de
sucre dans le cerveau parce que là ça va
il va en avoir besoin
les deux joueurs qui ont encore 16
minutes donc on n'est pas encore dans le
money time de la partie mais on est à un
tournant
un tournant de la partie après à ce
niveau là ils sont capables de se rendre
coup pour coup et trouver tous les
meilleurs coups et est rentré plus tard
dans une dans une finale est retardée
finalement l'échéance très souvent un
sas rarement par ko très vite c'est
parti au début les joueurs sont très
bien préparés donc c'est un peu du par
coeur ou chacun récit de son travail
qu'il a fait à la maison avec son équipe
de seconde en 16 entraîné un quoi et
puis arrive le moment où finalement on
sort de là et c'est débattre entre les
deux des problèmes contre à résoudre sur
sur l'échiquier sur les troubles mardi
la prendre alors une petite précision
aussi fab en ce qui concerne les mesures
contre la triche puisque c'est quand
même important d'en parler sur ses
tourments internes est donc là les
joueurs sont tous
tous les joueurs sont filmés à la caméra
il y à un arbitre officiel qui regarde
la caméra ils sont obligés aussi de
partager leurs écrans donc larbitre voix
l'écran d'ordinateur des joueurs
absolument tout ce que les joueurs
regardent sur leur écran d'ordinateur et
il peut aussi leur demande et j'ai vu ça
tu sais dans la préparation du match
alors que je mettais la caméra de maxime
que leurs beats a demandé à maxime il
veut demander à tout moment aux joueurs
de prendre sa caméra et de tourner
autour pour pourvoir tout ce qu'il y a
dans la dans la pièce est tout ce qu'il
ya autour de lui et je crois aussi qu'il
peut obliger le joueur a allumé des
micros pour entendre absolument tout ce
qui se passe je vais bien sûr que ce
soit automatique mais ça ça peut aussi
être rajoutés nommé en place pas mal de
trucs quand c'est bien parce que
rappelons-le a c'est l'un des problèmes
pour s'étendre sur internet c'est ça
c'est que comme l'ordinateur est devenu
beaucoup trop fort pour nous les hommes
si jamais on peut avoir le conseil de
l'ordinateur par quelques coups joués
pas ça serait une grosse aide et s'il ya
personne pour surveiller et 20 premières
des gens tentés de le faire et donc là
de tout bien mettre en place avec ce
tout ce processus anti cheating situe
vers une autre mesure aussi qui a été
prise c'est que 80% en gros un patch
pour % près mais en gros 80% du prize
pool du tournoi va être divisé
entre les équipes de manière égale et
donc en réalité alors il ya je crois que
l'équipe vainqueur gagne 24 mille
dollars et les finalistes 12000 de
mémoire on pourra regarder donc c'est
pas d'informations qu'on pourrait
vérifier après mai mais il ya 180 mille
dollars de prize pool en tout est donc
là que trente six mille dollars vraiment
en jeu dans la compétition et le reste
de l'argent et partager sa garantie
garantie ce qui pèse forcément aussi la
tentation éventuelle fab de tricher
j'avais d'énormes mesures et en plus le
jeu n'en vaudrait pas la chandelle pour
ces foires n'ont donc donc donc voilà
j'ai des bonnes mesures c'est bien et si
on trouve un bon moyen justement
d'éviter ces problèmes pour avoir de
plus en plus de compétitions online pour
nous oui donc maxime qui continue de cet
aliment terre ils oublient pas c'est
bien mais c'est ça fait partie du
professionnalisme aussi des échecs c'est
important et c'est pas important souvent
pour maintenant c'est important pendant
15 20 30 minutes fabre et puis souvent
bon là encore c'est une cadence rapide
un espion les parties d'échecs dure très
longtemps
fait rare la partie 5h 6h et là pour
coup faut vraiment duré longtemps et
donc j'en ai mangé des fruits secs des
choses comme ça il me connaît bonne
alimentation allant des haricots par
exemple des choses comme ça ouais ouais
et puis aussi même des protéines la
viande blanche du poulet ça peut ça peut
être une alimentation intéressante du
coup
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils aient le choix
pour lesquels on parle de l'équipe de
russie dans le chatt écouter on sait pas
exactement c'est le choix des
entraîneurs il faut il faut leur
demander à chis surprenant femme qui
nous arrive
côté dépôt alors ils laissent le pion
emprise mais il a une idée à la fin
j'imagine c'est de se venger sur le
cavalier e 2 qui serait acquis soeur en
l'air ça c'est la surcharge de la dame
qui donc de base et passez donc sur la
case d2 et qui défend le kabyle est
juste à côté
mais en même temps est de là-bas mais on
peut pas faire deux choses à la fois
donc il faut qu'on est parti on n'est
plus là donc acheté 500 prises mais
c'est plus simple un pion un tueur
empoisonné ouais c'est un miracle je
crois il n'est pas vraiment en prison
mais bon combat peut-être que je peux
plus reculer ou alors s'échanger contre
le local à vide si on venait prendre le
cavalier renforcerait plus ou moins la
reprise est peut-être un coup de
cavaillé g3 maintenant fab avec l'idée
de dire aux noirs écoutons fou g6 il va
falloir g4 pardon il va falloir qu'ils
reviennent au bercail mais c'est pas
facile à trouver comment non mais là ça
je crois quand même c'est ça alors
peut-être qu'il y aurait des miracles à
base de chou h4 ou je sais pas quoi mais
ça commence à être 5 loisirs le moindre
écart et c'est un fou qui disparaît
après on se doute que si le nepomniachi
numéro quatre mondial a réfléchi autant
de temps pour jouer à 6 ans il admis on
a en allaitant elle a mis cinq minutes
et une seconde pour jouer sur le bout
s'il a mis autant de temps c'est qu'il a
bien une idée derrière derrière la tête
et je pense que de toute façon on va
bientôt la voir puisque la variante par
et quoi qu'il en soit ma loge et
logiquement qu'ils valent et 8-k les g3
sur ces logiques après normal que maxime
brenet de son temps quand même pour voir
s'il a pas mieux puisque est a priori un
aiguillage si surprenant je m'attendais
pas trop à ce coup de base
alors est-ce que c'est pas si voudrait
après vous prend vous prend qu'un
réaliser 3 à les toucher cette case g5
touchée la nappe
non ça c'est très possible que ce sont
ces une amélioration pour ce fou de
kasghar des noirs
bloqué derrière ses pions il passe
devant la structure pions et contrôlons
l'aï vraiment actif on voit des gamins
écoute c'est la plantation c'est la
partie justement c'est ce que les
joueurs vont jouer ça paraissait être la
variante critique de toute façon parce
que sinon on trouve pas d'utilité à
squash si ces dames 1
à demain ça peut servir à pas se faire
toucher la dame un jour par du full 3d
ça et puis contrôle aussi un peu la
classe l'a pas ou mal à ça je crois je
pense aux menaces a je crois
complètement à plat le fou ne serait pas
perdu ils pourraient avoir accès à la
case h 5 mai le jour on le prendrait sa
cage la structure interne alors on peut
faire h 3 x 5 regard quelque chose de
joli cavaliers sa poule fou prend le 1
gagne la dame n'est pas pour longtemps
mais pas pondre et ont récupéré ont
récupéré la dame adverse donc maxime
j'ai l'impression qu'il est en train de
prendre le dessus fabre on va on va
laisser l'ordinateur un petit peu
réfléchir pour qu'il nous donne une
jauge et la jauge qui commence à rentrer
dans la 5e 15e grand pellegrin non mais
le courage trois verres assez logique
oui et même que vu que ça ne marche
absolument pas les normes h 3 x 5 km et
rend fou c'est joué d'ailleurs c'est
jouer ces jouets maxime qui était en
train de faire mal à l'équipe de russie
un en tout cas qui met sous pression
jouer à russe et qui pourrait prendre le
premier point pour pour l'europe dans ce
match peut-être un petit tour des stades
rapide pour voir ce que font les ai
cliqué aller alors les vannes aronian
avec les pièces noires on va pas rester
longtemps un fait c'est juste pour se
faire un avis il est bien vrai qu'il est
beau il est pas mal position solide
contre
contre vladislav artemiev les filles
alexandra gage carulla ça me fait peur
la femme quand je vois une jauge qui
montent comme ça ça se passe pas très
bien alors pourquoi c'est vrai que les
pièces blanches semble le problème c'est
que je suis fou johnny kidd et des noirs
c'est que si fou prend qui ont en bessin
qui veulent reprendre des saints qui met
sa tête
savate accumulé beaucoup de pièces
souvent la colonne des est peut-être
déjà un fils à bhl c'est pas possible
bon bah oui et surtout grand paris pour
dire et sam hanna serait déjà tour
campagne prend est fou c'est 4 la même
chose et deuxième truc c'est que ce fou
des 5 peut pas s'en aller enfin peut
sembler mais il ya le fou des six
dernières emprise mai et le 2 il a fait
120 battre en plus via voilà donc
beaucoup de problèmes et du coup c'est
un peu une position d'équilibriste pour
la noire sap a l'air simple du tout pour
la musique soutient comme on l'annoncé
en début de match 7 grillage qui n'a on
l'avait on l'avait noté 1
elle est très dangereuse ouais donc
larry klein puis en plein progrès pascal
à ces jeunes un et la numéro 3 mondiale
a fait chuter le champion du monde c'est
un autre en puissance et elle a pris une
option beaucoup toi c'est les coups
qu'on avait un si bel et alors je ne
sais pas si elle va jouer tour dès
maintenant on pense au gua mais il ya
quelque chose de fragile dans la
pollution noir et ça a l'air d'être
confirmé en tout cas par la jauge de
l'ordinateur et donc qu'il nous reste
en dernier lieu à la barre toussaint on
prendrait un quine
ces parties qui est parti pour durer
équilibré ce qu'on appelle pour les
noirs un hérisson 1 avec des pions 1 qui
piquent fait ça ils sont tous un peu
aligné et ont peu de gars tranchée par
là ce n'est ce pas le cinquième branche
de vieux personne n'a accès à l'étude
les cons
compte tenu des joueurs français et sa
part être une partie décisive pour
l'équipe d'europe parce que sur les deux
autres partis les européens s'ils n'ont
pas forcément le dessus c'est cul du web
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un gros
problème à chanaz musi tchouk est le
seul endroit où les européens sont un
peu de vent c'est notre maxime nationale
et il va falloir que maxime tir l'europe
vers le haut et aïe aïe nous chercher
deux points
finalement l'avenir de l'europe repose
sur un joueur français et affable rien
d'étonnant des tracts pour le coup pour
reparler du format des matches là comme
tout le monde joue en même temps les
joueurs peuvent un peu garder un oeil
sur ce qui se passe chez leurs collègues
je sais pas si kasparov peut communiquer
avec eux bonjour à cannes 4 le capitaine
donc de cette équipe j'ai dit reprend sa
semaine européenne de se l'approprier
10.1 des françaises est il pour le coup
et ça peut changer parce que si on voit
que l'équipe est en difficulté
finalement un moment prendre plus de
risques parce que on peut dire oui ils
vont perdre 3 1 ou 2 et demi un an et
demi la belle affaire c'est pareil donc
peut-être essayer d'arracher le match
nul ou quoi et c'est ça qui peut changer
par rapport tu vois un format à venir
coupe davis où les joueurs joueraient
les uns après les autres
las la rue en même temps où tu peux voir
tes collègues partis wallemacq et bien 7
0 un match de retard qui dit bombe à
pousser quoi oui mais ça a pas
spécialement change ta manière de jouer
pour le coc tennis
ces derniers tournages se sont à peine
le choix mais aux échecs des fois tu as
une position cadre équilibré et comme
nul est possible alors ça c'est un beau
tennis pour tous à la guinée de mon
exemple pour le coup bah tu peux dire ok
bah tant pis je vous prends tout mais
aux échecs
tu peux tu peux un peu changé ton s'il
veut plus enfants s'ils voulaient plus
en pluie plus en france une ré rôle pour
asseoir et voir un psy un petit peu là
du coup plutôt comme au football je
dirai où tu peux changer ta composition
faire sortir un attaquant fait rentrer
un défenseur
ça veut pas dire que tu prendras pas de
but ou que tu en marquera plus ça veut
pas dire ça ça veut juste dire que si tu
joues en 5 4 1 bat est censé être quand
même plus solide que si tu joues en 3 5
2 après après les joueurs pour
l'animation
donc après tout peut arriver mais aux
échecs voilà on peut avoir un peu cette
même question il doit y avoir le choix
entre deux trois coups qui semble de
force égale mais y en a un qui va être
un peu plus risqué qui va donner une
position plus compliqué où il y aura
plus possibilité d'erreurs et un autre
coup qui va être plus en contrôle pour
au pire mené une partie vers la nulle
sans progrès parce qu aux échecs déjà en
bois très très fort calcul est très très
loin c'est pas possible tout voir
jusqu'au bout donc un moment il ya des
choix à faire donc tour ses huit joué
par ian nepomniachi qui vient gagner un
temps ce qu'on appelle un tempo sur le
cavalier mais finalement fab ce qu'avait
dit on avait envie de le ramener vers b4
et des 5
donc autant le faire maintenant on est
plus en plus la dame en e1 bien placés
en elle elle protégera le cavalier en k2
en cas de menaces et même si la dame
bougeant e set pour se dire je vais
faire un tour intermédiaire ben j'ai
envie de te dire non voilà que les bêtas
a joué rapidement par maxime qui
commence aussi à mettre la pression sur
la pendule alors il reste encore 10
minutes à yann nepomniachi c'est long
mais il pourrait faire un peu la gueule
dans quand il en restera plus que deux
ou trois sur la pendule sarah son
importance plus tard parce que c'est ce
qu'on appelle à la fin le zeit note donc
c'est un mot allemand que ya pas plus de
temps et quand on insulte un peu plus
trop réfléchir c'est bien des coûts
réflexes et s'il ya des petites
subtilités dans la position sera très
difficile de me wade peut y avoir ce
qu'on appelle une gaffe aux siens une
grosse erreur due au manque de temps ça
arrive même à leur niveau quand on est
sous pression et on nous propose le coup
j'ai prend f5 éventuellement pour les
noirs avec l'imaginent comme idée sur
qui on te rend fou de jouer f4 et de
capitaliser fap sur le courage
exactement du lecavalier g3 peux pas
trop bouger
alors après ce qu on ne va pas quand
même ton idée de base le cavalier h st
alors partir quand même en disant je
suis cloué mais si tu prends je te
refais cette fourchette pour récupérer
la table donc les noirs enchaînerait
j'imagine par dame prend g4 pour
protéger le fou attaqué la dame et
garder le cavaly sous pression et
peut-être d'âme des uns obligé pour
retirer la table son attaque directe et
les fendre par rayons x en dire le
cabinet belge et 5 pour éviter les
changes des dames lorsqu'on est moins
bien dans la partie et les blancs
auraient une pièce de plus dans une
position compliquée on va voir fac j'ai
vu qu'il ya eu des coups on va retourner
tout de suite choisir les blancs cette
position et il a pris au f5 one lavande
est assez fort c'est quand même un bas
l'autre option
l'autre option c'est de ne pas prendre
le chou pour pas qu'il croit j'ai juste
reprendre le club et maintenir la menace
sur le fou exactement tu maintiens
assure le foot je peux aussi temps dans
l'est avec ta dam peut-être henri iv
parce que tu laisses ton cas légers 3
mais tu prends l'autre foutu fait échec
et 28 le montrer à un coup en bas blancs
des noirs est donc cette idée voilà où
on va manger les deux coup sur coup
comme les chats qu'il faut pas rigoler
ce de l'échec en priorité soit en
interceptant soit en bougeant en prenant
la caisse claude l'échec
bon bah lacour coup y'a que l'option de
la fuite et le fou qui tombe
ouais et ça aucun sens a gagné parce que
c'est un cavalier de plus ces pièces
très minces c'est déjà un pion suffit à
leur niveau pour gagner la plupart du
temps voilà une pièce plus forts
confiants et donc qui on prend avec son
ex blake sacré fait en maxime là deux
bonnes options ça peut être la
difficulté pour lui et la joie que
l'ordinateur proposant un tout cas même
si ce qui est assez malin avec l'idée
sur pions prend g4 de prolonger trois
pranger 3 et jouer à cinq je lit du
cavaliere fait qu'il ya pas de casse de
recul il peut aller se mettre au courant
à 6 c'est sa seule case libre mais ça
n'a pas duré longtemps car je veux juste
montrer surtout que les casques ont à
elles sont toutes contrôlées par les
noirs mais on the on a déjà des pions
dessus donc ne pas s'auto manger du
couple cavalier en a six ouais mais bon
il faudrait deux coups pour aller le
chercher
donc ça laissera maxime peut-être le
temps de en profiter pour faire autre
chose ouais c'est qu'on voit pas le
sauver mais pense que d'un comprend
ils sont pâles à s'occuper ce qui se
passe du côté de leurs droits par
exemple donc ça peut aussi être une
option
oui non mais je crois que quasiment que
des bonnes options pour les blancs donc
maxime en bonne posture après un truc
difficile aux échecs c'est que même
quand on est bien floral va finir la
partie surtout à ce niveau là sur ce see
en tout cas maxime qui est concentré il
lui reste onze minutes donc il a quand
même le temps de réfléchir on a
l'impression qu'il est en train de
prendre la souris en tout cas il en
train de prendre une décision
irréfléchie maxime on le voit sur la
caméra je sens qu'il est en position de
prise de décision là fabien et il vient
de prendre le pion et moi qui ai aussi
accès à son petit écran du coup je peux
voir mais je suis pas arbitre 1 mais je
vois que il allait les autres échiquiers
ouvert donc évidemment il regarde pas
les partis en même temps parce qu'il
aurait pas le pas le temps mais il a
quand même les échiquiers ouvert au cas
où pour pouvoir avoir accès aux autres
partis en un simple clic ou aux mines
powa minima avoir les résultats qui
s'affichent sur son écran pour savoir en
fin de partie s'il doit forcément pas
donc les joueurs qui sont prêts à
regarder leurs équipiers pour pour
savoir ce qu'il faut qu'ils fassent donc
mais dont que devient cette capture du
pion qui libère la case leucate pour la
dame et puis au mas options ça peut être
une épine pour les marques si un jour en
mer un f6 par exemple ça prend des
cadeaux autour du roi ça peut ramener
des pièces et ses accès terrain
ouais non les blancs maxime qui a
vraiment une position agréable je suis
surpris que la jauge blanche soit pas
soit pas plus haute fab
c'est peut-être que que visuel mais
peut-être l'ordi il va pas assez loin au
fond d'un robot exactement de je ne sais
pas ouais ou alors peut-être que les
coûts noirs sont sont très difficiles à
trouver qu'il faut faire une série de
coups improbables
exactement c'est pas facile mais bon
après il en est capable un dépôt ça me
joins oula tu as regardé à 5 heures max
qui a pris direct le flou il n'a pas
hésité à faire autre chose et il
mais paul est ce qui prend de calais
tout de suite justement il se dit j'ai
le temps parce qu'on a vu qu'il n'avait
pas 2015 de fuite et qui va plutôt
blinder sa position avant où je sais pas
ce que c'est vrai que le pion aux 5es
emprise celle ci prend b4 ça laisserait
à maxime l'occasion d'aller prendre le
pion aux 5 et ce qui est important à
l'exception de 5
c'est aussi les casques le pion contrôle
1 et que ça lui permettrait peut-être de
faire des choses là on va voir ce qu'il
a décidé de jouer
il a joué à prendre b4 à et maxime qui a
joué cavalier peut 4 bat la fameuse idée
de la fourchette à la fin et donc qui
rentre de manière forcée les coûts sont
sans aller vite mais on avait vu l'idée
plusieurs fois ils échangent les dan et
il rentre dans cette finale alors il
reste combien de qui on est à égalité
matérielle à l'heure actuelle
en gagnant mais on sera gagnant soitec a
les pensions sont fera tout reprend fou
on sera mollo qui a validé et on fera
l'option après que d'autres tours qui
sera bien du tout donc maxime qui
pourrait se retrouver avec un ton de
plus fin qui va se retrouve avec un plan
plus dans la finale alors ça peut
suffire pour regagner une partie à ce
niveau là en option de plus ouais il est
bien il est bien fabrique pour mettre le
point donc c'est peut-être l'occasion
fab de refaire un tour sur les
échiquiers pour pour se faire une idée
et surtout sur la position d'un amouzou
qui semble qu'ils semblent fab
en tout cas on voit à la jauge le moment
tenir mieux qui qu'on le pensait même si
un grand danger sur à la diagonale avec
une batterie et éventuellement cette
dame prend g7 qui pourrait qui pourrait
tourner et on va continuer à tour des
stades leeuwen aronian avec les noirs il
ya eu un sacrifice de qualité de la part
d' artemiev il a un pion pour la qualité
mais les pièces noires sont complètement
fermés et un plan de com h 4h 5h 6h 7h
800d difficile à arrêter fable oui les
pieds en plus sur sa route une fois que
ceux qui ont un âge si spira des dames
g7 pire des choses c'est vrai que c'est
pas facile
bon l'ordinateur alors dire que là il ya
un coût qui doit gagner absolument
ces papillons prend aussi sain pour ceux
qui le pain c'est parce que d'un petit
dame je sais pas le fait qu'il n'a
peut-être pas car derrière ça se sent
qu'il ya un souci côté noir
donc l'idée de 2,2 les vannes je
conserve le huitième rang des 500 m et
x6 lui permettrait de contrôler un peu
le pion h d'ailleurs exactement
peut-être qu'on sait très bien je vais
bien
parce que si on se fait prendre le pion
on va pousser et vice versa on va
prendre mais on va prendre et tout
reprendre n'est pas possible parce qu'il
ya l'autre tour maria donc la tour de
termes d'âge sur de boucliers et et puis
n'oublions pour reprendre de toute façon
parce qu'il ya l'euro 1
voilà le roi noir se trouverait en grand
danger et donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
fabing un sacrifice d'obstruction oui on
voulait faire ce pion franck ion vous
pouvez pas si les deux dames face à face
et danton à se faire prendre d'art et 11
ans au cou de pions au passage on bloque
et s'y prend on pousse reppion 6 on
aurait très très julien secoué cinq
fables vraiment vraiment très esthétique
1 c'est rare de voir comme ça quatre
pions face à face qui peuvent se manger
c'est vraiment rare que qu'on aime faire
ça aux échecs et la voilà on voit un
sacrifice joli mais qui va donner un
point aux rues sales à mon avis artemiev
le point va rentrer un côté côté russe
même s'il a que cinq minutes à la porte
ça va suffire largement je pense parce
que rappelons le il ya dix secondes de
rage ou par coup joué donc ça change pas
grand-chose de base mais à la fin quand
on a plus de 30 secondes bas ça laisse
un peu de temps pour pour finir
proprement la partie matheron panique
avec sa souris en tremblant etc
et côté police fighter contre contre
andreï kiné il semblerait que ce soit le
joueur européen à la fab qui ai pris un
avantage c'est vrai qu'il a plus plus d
espace à dame en f2 flambée 6 le pion à
6 en ligne de mire les tours blanches
qui quand même semble plus active le x 8
complètement murray dans les pionts et
le fou g7 qui s'est pris un thème aux
échecs la diagonale vide dont qui tape
il à la dernière grande ouverte mais ces
stratégies d'évitement côté duda je je
je te laisse ont ouvert mais il n'y a
rien à manger
l'exact le mans donc c'est pas de chance
non
bon là c'est parti c'est pas encore
clair mais c'est vrai que comme tu lis
est pareillement le blanc parce que vu
déjà dans cette position d' attaques de
classe le pion à six et la tour ont dû
vite c'est à dire tout défaut pendant un
temps ouais et duda on disait avant
disait en discussions d'avant d'avant
compétition on pensait que c'était un
gros point fort pour l'équipe européenne
ce troisième échiquier il est très bon
en rapide tu l'as tu l'as dit il a été
2e ou 3e aux championnats du monde il ya
deux ans toujours motivé bon sur
internet il a toutes les qualités
requises pour remettre des points et
c'est vrai qu'au troisième échiquier
avoir un joueur de ce calibre là c'est
un luxe et un côté européen c'est un mix
mix et puis c'est bien d'avoir des
jeunes joueurs car justement ils sont
motivés ils donnent tout cas alors on va
retourner du côté de maxime il s'est
passé pas mal de choses on va faire en
avance rapide pour revenir rapidement
sur le direct donc ça eu ces échanges ce
pion plus côté blanc et
et les noirs qui quand même vont essayer
de trouver du contre je peux être avec
ses pions b et le roi aussi qui pourrait
venir angers 6 un jour pour venir s'en
prendre voilà il vient d'ailleurs tout
de suite pour protéger le pion et s'en
prendre aux pions blancs
est-ce que ça va suffire pour gagner aux
côtés côté européen
voilà sa joie toute blinde il va
sûrement ramener sa tour voilà et pour
aller prendre l'autre pions bd blanc et
il va lui taper f
et ça semble pas suffire j'imaginais une
variante hussein le retour des quatre
corps prend b2 b5 roi prend existe une
variante assez logique et
malheureusement ça semble être un peu
juste
j'espère qu'on enferme un des deux bars
et salles pour la demande d'adoption de
pulse 2 points faisait que les noirs ils
vont attaquer là on va redescendre à
gâteaux à devoir attaquer l'autre si on
revient défendre la tournée en cours un
grand sac et bien sûr les deux de
préférence je donnerai le pion du centre
pour garder un pion pas ces allèles un
peu préoccupé et noir mais comment d'un
peu plus de l'autre côté ça va pas être
facile
les noirs en fait ils iront snapple vont
avoir ce qu'on appelle la position
préférentielle par la tour derrière lui
repasser donc c'est un pion qui peut
s'il a reims jusqu'au bout aléa
promotion se transformer en une pièce
plus forte
j'ai rarement une dame mais le truc
c'est donc ces tours là le pion va
l'empêcher d'accomplir se plaint et ont
retrouvé qu'une tour blanche en bibitte
là bas bloqué par son propre pions si on
fait un déplacement sur le côté bah on
sera prendre l'option et quoi faire pour
2 intéressant il ya rien c'est mort
donc même si la blessure est avantageuse
il ya de grandes chances que les nains à
la mettre en place un peu cette sorte de
forteresse on va dire pour pour tenir
dans la difficulté
belle défense du joueur
du joueur russe du coup dans cette
partie alors prêt reste à voir si maxime
boire une petite idée dans un petit
piège à un moment une peau de banane
pour que la nul ne soit pas si simple à
trouver pour son adversaire mais belle
défense de l'énergie parce que je
pensais que ça allait gagner
pour maxime ont simplement peut-être pas
mais assez voilà un qui a une très bonne
chance de gagner on va dire et là me
pour le coup maintenant jo ça je je
pense qu'ils créent sur la mule on va
aller voir je vois que on va en voir un
petit peu voir ce qui se passe dans les
partis qui sont quasiment finis tours 7e
5 tours ses huit passes qui reste plus
que deux minutes pour ladislas artemiev
fab est ce que est ce qu'on pourra avoir
un sauvetage miracle côté aronian où la
position est vraiment trop facile pour
le joueur russe bourgogne on peut
toujours mais est ce que tu t'es nef qui
pilonnait offensive 1 il envoie sa tour
il veut coulisser sur le côté et
descendre dès maintenant si tu souhaites
il serait peut-être possible fab d'aller
d' aller choper la caméra de l'even pour
voir quasiment deux parties alors les
von goethe attendre une petite seconde
je vais récupérer sa came si j'y arrive
ça arrive
et du coup sûrement il faut s'en firent
à clairoix parce qu'en plus la contre
attaque des noirs
à base de dame je sais pas eu trois pour
faire du tour c'est un et les maths et
dames 3 il y aurait le 3e set et nadal
entreprises donc les vins on regarde
s'il fait un peu qui fait un peu la
grise mine
ouais on voit que c'est dur pour le
joueur européen la joueurs arménien we5
le body language
c'est vrai qu'il a pas de meilleur body
language mais elle regarde il regarde
vers le regard il fait la moue un bon là
c'est que c'est foutu
après ça dépend plus de lui en fait lui
va essayer de défendre le mieux possible
si son adversaire jouer mon couple y
jouera et s'impose en voilà mais bombe
essayé d'appeler dedans et plus de
résistance possible et puis si jamais un
mirage se passe va être là pour pour
commencer meas n'aimons pas c'est qu'il
est ce qu'on appelle une enfilade donc
truc c'est que la dame est attaqué sur
n'importe quel déplacement de la dame
les blancs en montrant de la tour là
haut et avancer la cata et bah sinon
fonds permanent on s'est peut-être moins
grave de perdre à la montre autour du
cou mais bon ça va faire un gros déficit
matériel et au final
alors ils essayent de jouer cette
position on voit le body language de le
trail est là mais bon de toute façon ça
change pas grand chose dans les échecs
c'est pas c'est pas du poker ou quoi
c'est pas un jeu de hasard donc de toute
façon quand on s'est perdus par le body
language que tu veux surtout sur
internet où elle gère que il va tenter
quelque chose avec ses deux tours mais
de toute façon là il ya dame est fou et
pion contre deux tours donc ça fait 9
points pour la dame +3 plus un ça ferait
13 points contre 10 points ya
l'équivalent d'une pièce davance net et
en plus le pion h semble promis à un
avenir radieux fab exactement exactement
bref on fait une dame de plus il ya
beaucoup de matériel en face c'est
d'avoir
c'est un bon sac deux tours c'est à peu
près la valeur d'une dame c'est plutôt
hors de leur juste deux tours mais là la
preuve c'est peu mais blanc n'ont pas
qu'une avance il faut et pyongyang de
lire ça fait un peu trop
oui c'est rh 4 août ou le faire puis
rouach 3 par exemple pour des clous et
pouvoir à nouveau faire jouer au fou qui
aidera défendre le pion passer des noirs
là qui pourra permettre mona sens il
descendait tout en bas et puis du coup
une fois qu'on a pris soin d'éviter le
contrôle des adverses exception alors
poussé nous-mêmes pions h fort inquiet
blanc et elle est bien un succès ça fait
quand même plaisir de revoir un an à
noronha devant un échiquier
come on come on le disait il à perdre
aux à sa femme le mois dernier à la
suite à un accident de voiture tragique
et c'est quand même ça me fait quand
même plaisir qui gagne qui perd depuis
je suis quand même content qu'ils
étaient invités qui joue pour l'équipe
européenne j'espère que kasparov sicilia
s'il est bonne le souhaite le laissera
rejouer demain même si ça coûte un point
ou deux à l'équipe
écoute c'est un joueur d'exception et ça
ça fait vraiment plaisir de le revoir en
action
notre club a besoin d'énergie qui se
remettra qui voit là se prendre le temps
de faire le deuil et c'est bien sûr plus
quelqu'un de vraiment sympa
il a apprécié de 2 1 les joueurs du haut
niveau il a apprécié de tous les joueurs
de haut niveau on peut aller voir la
joueuse européenne fab anna musi tchouk
donc je crois qu'elle sonnait bien
sortir je pense pas qu'elle soit moins
bien maintenant on était très résistante
et la pression va être très symétrique
un an après les changes des cavaliers
ouais parce qu'on fait d'un v6 d'avant
où seront échanges tout de suite je sais
pas parce que sur les changes peut être
durable dam des cinq échecs
puis un peu de les nier que je vais dire
est ce que c'est grave en même temps
c'est pas non plus la fin du monde mais
on peut aussi ramener la dame noire
glossy ce bien contrôler un peu tout nam
centralisée souvent très fort et
ensuite je pour prendre dame insiste
d'abord semble semble être plus précis
on va voir ce qu'elle décide de faire
est ce que parfois quand tu as une
position comme ça elle était moins bien
elle sait qu'elle a été moins bien
il reste six minutes contre une
quarantaine ce que tu peux avoir envie
de punir et d'aller carrément chercher
chercher la gagne côté noir fab en fait
c'est très bien c'est l'apanage des
grands champions dans le vert car ça
parce qu'en fait trop souvent tu restes
quand on a l'impression de jouer pour la
nul c'était super mal et qu'il faut que
sauf que je sauve et le jour où tu peux
sauver tu souffles regarde même plus et
avait une chance de gagner ou pas et et
que tu gagnes pas ça va faire ça c'est
important de changer de mindset en fait
de passer de sauver la partie amont a
gagné elle changer de braquet
mais c'est pas tout le monde qui peut le
faire ça tout cas c'est ce qu'elle
essaye de faire un as pour pour l'europe
jose ukrainienne donc tu es tu vas
l'éperon v6 il va sûrement y avoir après
pions prend dam des cinq échecs mais
j'imagine que la joueuse ukrainienne
représentant l'europe doit se poser la
question d'un dames 3 échecs
intermédiaire un petit intermezzo qui
permettrait de protéger le fou peut-être
ça peut être utile dans certaines
variantes mais le pion au f5 ne serais
plus protégée alors voilà il ya les deux
voies l'une contre l'autre évolution qui
va y avoir un jour de paix rhdp d'un
échec perpétuerait la wii avec leurs
loisirs autour de la dame mais en tout
cas c'est un un demi point sauvé
important important est important après
maintenant comme les bonnes banques a
perdu c'est officiel il s'est incliné
jeu résultats maxime va peut-être pas
gagné
il faut absolument que donc duda ou
troisième échiquier l'emportent pour
faire match nul contre la russie on va
on va aller c'est peut-être là nul ce
se passer dans cette partie on va voir
si elle choisit de faire roi ait fuité
revenir moi j'ai six aussi et peut-être
une option mais après dame si c'est ce
que ça apporte vraiment quelque chose
d'être fou et 6
je sais pas si on a vraiment intérêt
j'ai l'impression qu'avec les noirs au
rendement des complications pour au pire
avoir mieux à voir ça
et au pire peut-être plus grave avec un
roi un petit peu en danger et fab nombre
d'appels va tenter si le match justement
ce qu'on faisait tout à l'heure si elle
voit que manger trop compromis quoi j'ai
dit bon ben ok je tente alors
objectivement pas juste répéter les
coups sans doute à duda écoute ça va
bien se passer
la regarde la jauge regarde la position
les deux pions blancs qui vont qui vont
monter la tour ans 17
ça va être un gain pour le joueur
européen qui va probablement égaliser et
maxime et maxime cette position aille
nuls d'ailleurs une proposition de nul
de la part de du joueur russe qui est
signée donc il semble que tout pourrait
se jouer fable sur sur ce point sur ces
jeunes filles 1 à nous ou qu'avec les
noirs nul la plus probable
et après on sait le prends risques tu
risquerais où tu risquerais pas moi je
suis très plus autre nom jeu très rapide
et je pense qu'elle va faire nous narrer
pour le coup ça vaut pas la peine parce
que en faisant nul déjà ta match nul
dans le match on dit au revoir le cada
leila confus mais ils s'envoyaient donc
en fait ça allait prendre un risque et
au lieu de faire lui-même tu la peur est
là et à tous tes coéquipiers ton gun
pourquoi tu as joué qu'est ce que c'est
que cela ils sont pas si content quand
tu la gagnes en fait alors nul l'annuler
et signés et donc on va aller voir le
dernier joueur on va aller on va aller
voir ce qu'ils donnent
il ya une christophe duda on va voir ce
qui nous donne en tout cas on peut dire
qu'il est moins moins bon caméraman que
maxime vachier lagrave
mais la mère de ksl puis à fond tous les
âges qui on a senti la déception sur une
variante mais où il s'était dit que ça
gagner tout de suite et non il avait
quitté le cube bien alors il ya beaucoup
de choses emprise côté noir là à l'heure
actuelle il ya la tour e mi-temps prise
il ya le cavaly 5 il ya le pion b6 qui
pourra avancer
donc il ya énormément d'arguments en
faveur du joueur polonais mais il ya
aussi la pression
il connaît le sort du match s'est il le
voit forcément il sait qu'ils sont menés
d'un point il sait qu'il doit aller
chercher la victoire pour égaliser et ça
ça te mets forcément une certaine
pression peut-être que je jouerais un
coup comme pion a fait un trou pour
râler de l'option la désobéissance de
bar de maintenant la main quelques
t'aurais pas envie d'encaisser à tour en
premier ben bernanke et sans la tour où
tu commences à calculer quelle épreuve
alors tu pour encaisser le cavalier
depuis la tour et oui mais en fait le
truc c'est qu'à ce moment là bas
sûrement que c'est le plus fort
collectivement mais je suis venu vous à
regarder s'il ya des t4 machin c'est ce
qu'il va faire
me2 alors ils attaquent le fou il
attaque le pion et il veut peut-être se
diriger vers à 6 pour aller faire parler
la tour parce que le joueur le joueur
russe n'a plus tour fab
on est en train d'aller chercher le
match nul ce qui est vraiment important
dans cette compétition commencé par une
défaite ça ait deux défaites dans la
même journée serait plus être dur et là
ça mettra moins de pression sur sur les
joueurs contre contre la chine duda qui
en train de de faire mal à son à son
adversaire russe fas ben ouais là non
non c'est bon quand même
alors qu'avec tout ce qui a des attaques
et toutes les menaces que da vinci ce
drame prince le chou déjà aussi en vert
c'est too much quoi boire je peux pas
tout sauver 8 alors il veut sur damas
six à avoir foulé cette fois encore
alors est-ce qu'un cavalier ces cinq
femmes peut-être pour essayer d'aller
mettre une fourchette peu ma faut
peut-être mais tu sais même que même
damas si c'était pas si mal fou 17 ans
allait changer l'état moussy aussi
possible
duda on se rappelle fac qui en pro de
chelsea qui avait joué sous les sous les
couleurs de votre équipe
il a fait des bons résultats on a vu
qu'ils un tout bon on avait on avait on
a eu et maxime vachier lagrave qui
voudraient encore avec nous et duda qui
avait joué avec nous ils de saison et
c'est vrai que ces deux hommes déjà en
compétition par clubs font mal et la
voilà le cavaly c5 qui est partie fab
est sûre dams et 8 pour essayer de jouer
sur le coup a juré bessette
bah non il y aurait juste pardon dame
d'apprendre je suis complètement taré
durée que j'apprends des grands fous qui
gagne mais en fait y'a plein pour
défendre caïds et celles qui menacent
donc la fourchette
le fou qui bouge et maintenant je donne
des 5 ou peut-être tmb 55 le 17
java les 17 cas f6 qu'il prend h5 pour
aller menacer des matchs aussi possible
ouais tout à l'air de gagner faut pas se
tromper fabre non l'état d'âme des 5
c'est bien tu contrôles toujours à
pousser à limbé cinq ans à la tête du
bon que tu vas 4-1-2-3 tout et c'est
finir mais du mas des cavaliers 17 aussi
est une menace des pcet est une menace
tous mais on sent la responsabilité dans
les coups ils regardent peut-être car
ali prend aussi sain d'ailleurs aussi
possible c'est peut-être le plus fort
mais quand tu as tellement bien simple
photo de bosses cent mille euros que ça
j'ai l'impression que c'est son style
fabre d'aller non mais tu vois que ça
marche ça marche il a raison dans le
plus pur des gens simples mortels comme
nous mais c'est un joueur qui a envie il
a envie de faire un lock out 1 ils ont
ils envie de m l'uppercut de mettre
l'adversaire ko est là clairement fabi
cherchent ils cherchent le ko il y dix
ans que son adversaire est dans les
cordes et il veut pas il veut pas le
laisser en vie veut pas laisser vivre un
coup de plus ces cavaliers pros aussi su
vois ça y est ils envoient le knock-out
il fait mal alors l'idée c'est que sur
fion prend d'impro 6,3 g s'est tu aurais
tour ses huit d'un pro v6 on aura
l'impression que les noirs récupère le
matériel mais tour g8 seront à vii est
d'amener 6 matt fab d'altran b6 jouer
directement maintenant tour ses huit
échecs le roi aurait été obligé de
partir vers h7 et dame prend à chaque
match donc doute à kia pas qui a bien
calculé qu'il ya pas laisser traîner et
qui gagne la partie n'est même pas très
heureux sur son visage son onze
le match n'est pas gagné quoi c
il est juste allé seul demi point non
mais il peut être content de sa partie
arrière bien joué après le truc c'est
que toute façon il ya une autre partie
qui commence non pas si longtemps que ça
en quarante minutes donc c'est pas le
moment d'aller savourer le champagne qui
doit déjà être focus sur sur la suite
alors on va nous faire avaler regarder
ce qui se passe dans les autres
rencontres la chine contre le reste du
monde pour le moment humaine mais je
vois que le match états unis inde est
très serré je te propose qu'on aille
voir la partie de fabiano caruana
je milite contre vie dit ouais
sûrement même à voir mais il ya plus
beaucoup de matériel chacun après il ya
grosso avantage à la pendule que j'avais
pas vu mais ça qu'il a dix minutes
contre 40 secondes ça ça peut jouer
ouais ouais ça peut ça peut être un
facteur fab
je veux voir si je trouve la deuxième
partie peut-être elle est terminée et je
n'ai pas le gérer c'est en ouvrant le
résultat de partout en europe etats unis
c'est le match qu'on cherchait et et je
vois pas l'autre partie donc sûrement
que le que le résultat va être mise à
jour rapidement de ce côté là à moi que
je le trouve là je peux les voir
de mon côté je fais toujours c'est à ton
ski conejo ouais ça joue toujours
mais koné ruine tout le monde est
d'accord donc ça veut dire que les
indiens bouge nous que les indiens
devraient devrait en fait le coup rouge
s'était passé de -8 les versions de
l'ordinateur à sare passé 0,54
en fait je sais pas tout varié alors
attends j'aurais bien mal à trouver
cette partie est ce que tu peux me
donner le pseudo shengli joueuse belge
en 58 ans là je regarde sur sur check
points comme cela chez ims way
du coup t'as pas le gbl
j'ai aucune idée ce que c'est leur mort
se porte donc on va se concentrer sur
cette partie qui nous tient au courant
cette finale quand même avec un pion
passé côté côté fabiano la paire de phu
an les deux fous qui joue souvent bien
de concerts puisqu'ils contrôlent les
cases blanches et les cases noires et le
pion à 7 qui pourraient être faibles un
jour si le fou réussit à atterrir en b 8
fab
ça pourrait être dangereux j'ai
l'impression que vu le vu le facteur du
temps fabiano pourrait aller chercher un
point possible et rue des
rebondissements dans la partie à côté
donc on ne voit pas mais ça a l'air
heureux gagnants pour koné on lui dit
qu'elle a repris l'aventage âge aux
indiennes
ça voudrait dire que les espoirs des
états unis les espoirs de match nul
repose sur les épaules du vice-champion
du monde fab exactement fabiano caruana
demande mondiale bien installés depuis
longtemps dans l'élite et e
et voilà c'est aussi un gagne du terrain
dans cette partie des coûts comme food
et 8 est envisageable si on venait
prendre le cavalier que le pion
reprenait sa les three lions à filer à
dame
il a fait fou et 5 avec l'idée peut-être
d'aller à toucher chatouiller ce pion
vrai que si tu gagnes à 7 après ça ça
file un vieux l'abandon de la nageuse
qui donc victoire de cohérent donc les
indiens qui prend le lead dans ce match
m et les indiens qui sont qui sont très
dangereux un fabuleux d'en parler avant
ils sont un petit peu sous classé au
niveau du vélo mais 7,7 koné rouault
dernière et she ciel peut faire mal à
beaucoup de monde c'est moi mais bon ils
ont quand même emmené par un ex champion
du monde vit chez allende au premier qui
a fait quoi aussi beaucoup alors vichy
qui a fait nul avec les pièces blanches
contre hikaru nakamura hockey et les
chemins nul contre dominguez est ok et
donc il ya cette partie là donc caruana
qui doit absolument l'emporter pour pour
égaliser pour son pays quoi oui alors il
ya eu ces quatre l'idée de ces quatre
ces deux
libérez la diagonale comme ça s'il faut
viande et 8 le footeux 3 pourra protéger
le plus lent à 7 et de plus le pion c4
fait ce don fab vous parlais tout à
l'heure le con tre jeu ils vont envoyer
deux contres jeu et éventuellement s'il
a eu jusque jusque dans l'en-but blanc
exactement et se transforme en une
nouvelle dame
le truc c'est que c'est pas si simple
puisque les fous contrôle beaucoup de
cases est déjà à la casse juste devant
ce pion est déjà contrôlé de boire des
efforts d'énergie pour y arriver à des
cavaliers ou décaler le fou pour aider
ce peuple mais en tout cas c'est le
projet des noirs ouais et après les
plans ou si leur roi qui peut être
utilisée est donc oui c'est vrai que la
paire de tout ça est bien avancée parce
que comme on a un coût de 15 manches en
15 mois on peut montrer toutes les cases
de vente pions et donc aider à le faire
monter graduellement comme ça alors est
ce que tu penses que les blancs vont
réussir à créer ce qu'on appelle le
concept des deux menaces cédé 2
faiblesse c'est à dire réussir à
focaliser les noirs sur le pion f pour
réussir à les taper de piora est ce que
tu penses que alors j'ai souvent il faut
faire et de faiblesse après j'ai aussi
peut-être simplement la méthode brut de
jouer à fond pour inscription et forcer
l'adversaire à sacrifier une pièce
dessus le chou le cavalier pas ce que
vaut mieux faire un fou un cavalier que
doit l'adversaire transformer soutien
aux nouvelles dalles et à ce moment là
avec la rondelle matériel ensuite
switcher pour aller manger tout reste
donc à voir comment la sar g est ce
qu'il va y arriver en plus c'est pas
facile c'est ça sans gagnant
techniquement mais il faut trouver ça
avec donc pas énormément de temps à la
pendule et en pratique problème c'est
que dès que tu fais un faux pas aux
échecs
tu peux perdre c'est un peu comme la
boxe on va dire hein t'as beau avoir
dominé tout le combat suprême eut
percuté un moment le premier cas au delà
l'idée ce serait de faire cavalier afif
ou price issoufou problème si c'est de
jouer avec ce qu'on appelle des fous de
couleurs opposées
c'est à dire que chaque joueur restera
avec le fou d'une couleur savent que les
blancs pour pousser le cuir adam aurait
besoin d'attaquer une case noire ils
n'ont pas de pièces pour le faire un
leroy est indélogeable et le fou pourra
s'occuper de la défense du pion donc les
deux pièces noir auront un rôle et les
blanc ne pourrait pas aller à dame donc
visite qui a une idée de défense claire
maintenant mettre le cavalier f6 est
allé chercher le match nul fab
voilà donc du coup et mille et une
deuxième vie des séquelles et 7,5 et
aller ils mangent union oui parce que ça
fait une fourchette donc faut tout
éviter avec les mains c'est pas vous y
est peut-être un gage de carnac et le
jeu trop vite trop bas de la passion son
adversaire et qui hélas se heurte un mur
alors est ce qui peut faire faut deux
pour essayer de se venger sur le pion c4
mais des échanges n'est pas forcément sa
faveur parce que moins il restera deux
pièces sur l'échiquier plus ce sera
compliqué mais ce qu on pourrait essayer
de tenter un passage en force comme ça
avec les blancs paris coûte c'est ce qui
va te sens tu es sûrement mais j'ai des
doutes quant au fait que ça puisse
vraiment gagner surtout qu'en plus quant
à plus de pions si les noirs et ça va
sacrifier leurs cavaliers sur ce qu une
grande ramenant un jour et en étant même
très donc à me donner contre l'option 2
fourrage ou sept nuls donc visite qui
pourrait prendre l'annuler ce serait sur
le papier une première surprise en mai
je t'en parler ce matin dont on a
discuté ce matin concernait le débrief
match et nous avait jamais un champion
s'est dit les gens vient très dangereux
tt tt tt - adam tapas au jeu est bon ce
sont des boss si dangereux que ça mais
exemple des bons coups
ah bah il pourrait battre enfin là l'un
des favoris après tout le monde et
favori de la compétition il ya peu
d'équipés toutes les équipes sont fortes
mais en tout cas les états unis était
placée dans le dans le trio dans le trio
de devant et voit ses indiens un peu
soupe la c'est un peu moins connus vie
dit harry krishna des joueurs un peu
moins cotés mais mais tout aussi fort et
là peut-être fois ci c'est un fait du
direct femme
3 - m6 et cavaliers ici à mais ils
seraient pas obligées forcément 2
mangez pas non mais bon il commença
façon blocus oui c'est très pénible
simplement c'est complètement nul ça
c'est proche de l'être
ouais bon si tu te trompes plus de 30
mais normalement c'est pas vous signifie
pas faire vraiment d'erreurs et c'est
pas très compliqué de dire et on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'une d'une gaffe un
échec surtout avec peu de temps la
pendule sous la pression d'un foulard de
la qualité de caruana puis il ya ma ou
slip
tu me malka pièce avec ta souris tu
lâches un peu avant 1h
ça peut arriver aux six autres quidams
mais bon normalement non si alpha molo à
des connexions ah oui ça se passe
comment ce ton ainsi une déconnexion est
je crois que surveille ta connection
tapantes est déconnecté non mais c'est
vrai que c'est un truc à prendre en
compte et je trouve c'est logique c'est
est déconnecté et tu as perdu ta faute
ou quoi mais donc varier de façon on a
déjà discuté sur l'action de la rivière
pas il n'ya pas de bonne solution c'est
toujours le même problème c'est parfois
la dette à des problèmes et chaque règle
que tu vas mettre en place aura ses
défauts et finalement et justement les
chinois ils ont fait quoi alors les
chinois les chinois les chinois les
chinois mais 2 1 mais il reste une fan
encore d'accord tu peux aller voir si tu
veux mon côté web roulotte et la partie
là mais tu peux nous dire est ce que les
chinois font ou dit fan ni moins un
dialogue ou iphone leur mondial c'est
fini peut-être les normes iphone et la
gagner a donc ça fait bien pour la chine
à la chimie qui direct met les points
sur les i quelque part ouais mais c'est
sûr ah non mais c'est oui je pense
clairement l'équipe de plus forte après
le papier que tu vas forcément gagner
mais on va se les coltiner un mais les
chinois très belle équipe
il gagne maintenant régulièrement les
olympiades c'est une sorte de joe des
échecs on va dire en quelques sortes
et donc ça veut dire beaucoup prêtent en
détail pour vous mais j'avais regardé un
peu la fiche de leur entraîneur donc gi
joe and the sexes est un très bon joueur
on le dit 90 des bises et 2000 je pense
d'ailleurs qu'ils jouaient dans le match
russie contraste du monde en 2001
constat est en fait donc c'est le
deuxième grand maître de l'histoire de
chine et il est ce titre début des
années 90 à 34 ans c'est nouveau donc ça
c'est nouveau en fait c'est bon signe à
30 ans mais c'est pas toi tu as tu
parles des russes aux échecs par exemple
oui prison depuis une centaine d'années
et donc la chine si oui plutôt récemment
de richesse et son bien comme il faut se
maintenant au roi qui règne en deux
saisons olympiades et c'est pas rien
en quelques dizaines d'années d'arriver
à devenir une des plus fortes nations et
là ils sont carrément favoris face à des
continents exactement c'est quand même
assez parlants fab alors fou j'ai cinq
visites qui s'accroche mais si cela est
bon pour le coup il ya quand même une
réussite avec les blancs ce qui l'a
chassé ce roi un peu et donc il est plus
dans le chemin du pion il réalise très
beaucoup plus gênant 1,2 en attente chez
de passer donc pas en cloud peut-être
peut-être un espoir pour le blanc je
sais pas alors en revanche si on devait
sacrifier le fou contre le pion ce
serait se serait probablement gagnant de
fou contre un cavalier saga je crois
ouais et puis quand bien même il y aura
des gens donnent déjà c'était très
différent
est ce qu'une des différences notoires
ce que va être le cas au lit peut se
faire clouer alors qu'un to face à un
fou c'est maïs manche à l'autre
ces feux contre-feu quoi voilà et donc
cette histoire de cavaliers cloué
ça fait qu'on peut se le faire manger m
et donc après bien sûr s'il reste avec
deux fourgons de leroy et basses pour
sagan donc c'est ce que a tenté de faire
bien fabien donc il veut chasser le fou
un peu de la diagonale pousse ses pions
chasser le lecavalier par non delà du
contrôle de la casaque six pouces et le
pion forcé deux fois à sacrifier compte
et après avoir les deux fous contre les
cavaliers gagner ça c'est l'idée du
joueur avec les blancs et l'idée du jour
avec les noirs du coup c'est garder son
que le mali au contrôle du pion et un
jour où parfois pas faire un cavalier g3
ou quoi et et simplement aller le mans
gmail assure qu'elle était trois le
temps avance nous exactement c'est ça
c'est d'ailleurs l'idée de foot est roi
de prendre aux cavaliers et suivons
wimborne donc sûrement qu'il a reculé de
26 à non à se bouger label emi en g3 et
bah du coup et la fa na waie et on
rentre dans cette finale
bah ça devrait gagner parce qu'en fait
donc le plan de relance allait gagner le
pion là-bas tout seul mais bon ça il
fallait le prendre assez facilement ça y
va les cueillir une fois que ça c'est
que yi on vend concertée lecavalier
attaquer un peu loin un peu le clouage
son cavalier et petit à petit le prendre
et mattek les deux joues on devrait on
devrait voir ça devrait avoir la femme
donc fois six blocs le pion oms a écrit
quinze ans on va l'attaquer sans qu'ils
puissent avancer et on va le prendre
et alors après on peut aussi avec les
blancs avoir l' envie de faire un peu de
boulot avant de prendre le pion ce qui
est une règle déchets qui s'appelle la
règle des 50 pouces mais à 50 coups sans
pousser thion ou sans prise ce qui est
rarissime un mais c'est à cent coups de
pions sans prise ou sans pousser les
pions
la partie est déclaré nul donc il peut
être intéressant d'essayer de faire un
peu de travail pour le moment voir ce
qui se passe avec le pion envier et puis
si dans 20 30 coût on voit que de toute
façon on est obligé de le prendre pour
libérer un peu fou on ira de prendre et
comme ça on ouvrira un nouveau chapitre
de 50 coups donc apparaît peu juste fait
refouler cette et fou prend donc il
avoir un omeyer anic et 1re cat donc
l'association prendre cavaliers ont ce
soir est bon un fou et donc roi fou va
pas gagner pour le coup pour ceux qui
savent pas
faut vraiment qu'on a nos deux chouchous
pour mater un roi est un fou tout seul
contraint à revoir ça va pas suffire
on n'y a aucun schéma de matelot si
c'est d'entourer le roi mais deux pions
qui paris ve qui veut forcer ils s'en
fichent en fait ce prix comprend qu'il
va le perdre mais doit dire plutôt de le
donne plus vivable et 5008 rude coup à
voilà c'est comme ça maintenant si je
défends une fois 50 coup c'est bon c'est
bon je veux ça une fois dans la vie
j'avais une position que j'essayais de
gagner et j'avais j'ai eu du mal face
était objectivement nul
j'avais tour fou est un pion voilà à
tour et d'options et en plus c'était
d'options sur lui même et j'avais tourné
49 coup je verrai réussi à faire puis
j'ai lancé mon client qui était sûr
après le rejet d'une case est en fait ca
atteint on adversaire psychologiquement
est sûre il ya encore le faire trois
fois la partie orange les 550 coup et
très vite j'ai gagné dans la deuxième
phase est présent mais c'était une
partie lente l'a déjà c'est un peu long
s'est départi d'une harpe mais je crois
qu'on était quasiment six heures de jeu
quand tu vois je je crois que c'était le
coup de grâce moralement d'ailleurs
chose rare à un fab dans cette partie
des joueurs vient d attendre d'atteindre
le centième coup un fou des 4 et le 100e
coût de la partie est assez rare fabien
à ce niveau là enfin tous les niveaux
d'ailleurs d'avoir des partis qui durent
son coût tout à fait et donc la couenne
des noirs ces camps turcs et valeo 4
si tu veux montrer ce sera juste mini
pédagogie pour cette finale il y aurait
poussé stis clouage du câble est ce
qu'on vous disait il peut plus bouger
ses doigts derrière et donc moi de
gagner ce cavalière et six autres
cavaliers 4 il allait en e2 on va dire
c'était fou d1
c'était un luxe hang on appelle en fait
le meilleur coup ça serait de ne pas
jouer avec les nerfs
ce qui est intéressant voilà donc il
doit jouer il ya que le roi quel droit
de bouger et on tombera de cavale voilà
donc c'est assez
clarence maroc les blancs en mydata mais
il a bien défendu vijay il n'a pas joué
le coup lorsque essaye de faire le jour
avec les blancs maintenant fabien
caruana c'est de couper le roi du
cavalier pour peut-être renfermé
lecavalier dans l'est
dans les toiles d'araignée des fous note
serait possible si le roi commence à
partir trop loin un jour les pièces
blanches pourrait contrôler toutes les
cases de rebond du cavalier et s'en
empare et la vraie c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils essaient de faire
mais pour le bâtiment ils n'y arrivent
pas un truc souvent dans vos propres
parties à cesser de mettre le x 3 cases
du câble et ça serait parfait
voilà le foot cases noires il ya trois
pièces du cavalier et il prend toutes
ces cases et donc est plus qu à
l'attaqué il peut aller nulle part
ça c'est le rêve des plans ça exactement
ce qu'on appelle une focale ça c'est le
rêve des blancs mais pour le moment ils
n'arrivent pas visite qui défend cammas
est bien en début de finale
pour le moment il réalise il réalise une
belle défense mais je doute qu'ils
réussissent à afféry dommage pour lui
parce que ça semblait vraiment très
proche de nuls champ's les nuls
objectivement des grains mais il s'est
fait repousser ce roi un peu loin ce qui
a permis à fabiano de gestion etc
bon maintenant on doit conclure comment
ce qu'elle va être enfermé parce qu'il
va il va faire les menaces et sur le roi
qui peut essayer de pousser dans le coin
et sur le carré dit qu'il essaye d'en
fermer
j'imagine par exemple que sur un coup
comme pour arracher cette maintenant ils
feraient faut être quatre le cavalier
n'aurait plus que deux cases libres sur
f1 on a déjà vu que c'était la fameuse
focale donc vous a parlé et silva en h1
fab je donne pas cher de sa peau
non pas trop je sais pas exactement
comment mais peut-être on pourrait
essayer de faire défaut cas de nouveau
je sais pas même mairie sans lequel les
bleus partout quelqu'un va lier un jour
finissent par par tomber alors il a fait
comment il a fait campagne âge 5
justement il veut mon revenir avec son
cavalier mais tu vois il commence aussi
maintenant à il multiplie multiplie les
idées fabiano s'en va avec les loyers
reculent toutes à leur vie mais à un
moment tu avais au bord de l'échiquier
dans l'est dans les cordes le roi il a
plus de 4 vers l'avant tu as les deux
fous qui crachent du feu la demande on
voit bien visuellement droit
a bien fait que le roi plus trop de
cases il va peut-être juste un petit
coup de foudre et 3 continué de
focaliser le cavalier justement et
repartir et par la droite dure faire
petit à petit tu réellement sur le
terrain un responsable pas faire un truc
je voulais faire fausse de f ou g 4 pour
essayer leur viendra peut-être peur que
catherine pas ça sent qu'il va tomber un
jour ou l'autre mais il faut être précis
avec les blancs alors voilà c'est toute
la difficulté va mais alors qu'aucun
journal chaussures intense fait que
cette coupe jeudi en sept finales qui
devient 50 oui puis qu'on appose son
septième en nous demandant le chat c'est
facile après de gagner créé de fou
contre le oui 3 le roi c'est très facile
à 6 voilà d'ailleurs dès qu'ils perdent
en cavalier il abandonnerait parce que
c'est vraiment très facile à réaliser et
déjà 16h27 fabiano qui aura pas
énormément de temps pour se reposer
ça reprend à 16h45 normalement c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils coûts de
remplacement des sculptures qu'est ce
que tu fais sortir caruana quand même
vice champion du monde
moi non mais par contre parce qu'en plus
surtout s'ils gagnent mais bon psy vie
dit il y à défendre il a défendu a
défendu et finit par perdre tu peux lui
laissait même scirocco oui puis revenir
demain exactement oui ça joue chaque
jour deux parties par jour sauf donc la
finale dimanche à 16 heures heure
française
exact donc ce cas ralliée qui va être
obligé de revenir au match 5 de nouveau
il veut regarder loin peut-être pour
l'accueillir
ouais mais il pourra repartir peut-être
f6 wife cinq jeux plus pauvres sont
laissés faire voir 5la d'autres parce
que c'est le coup mais est comme ça sur
kg 3 roger quatre chanteuses parvient ou
google
d'accord on gagne il sera obligé d'aller
vers agen il y aura un envoi est à noter
un regarder la puissance des fous qui
boxe lors à 9 3 qui est bloquée
complètement bloquée sur wyeth pour rien
faire [ __ ] 5 pour t'amuser
regardez la naissance des fous on se met
en cage
le roi blanc mardi
le cavalier qui lui aussi en cage et
puis après on pourra mener ensemble pour
finir le rendre vers ce qu'on va bientôt
voir un abandon un fab dans cette partie
fabiano qui réfléchit il a fait un truc
alors se croiser et katia encore car il
faut bien attendre ce qu'elle soit
partie vers les trains mais peut-être un
petit tu foutais 5 où je sais pas
attention ne pas faire flouer de l'or
qui serait une grave erreur ça
s'appliquerait et c'est ce qui est
arrivé aux seychelles
c'est que tu as bien je pense entrer ce
coup de moins bien et tu fais fou de
déconcentrer 3 secondes et petite
fourche là têtus fait nul et c'est fini
ça arrive ça arrive trop souvent ça
arrive et pas qu'aux autres
heureusement ah ben ça arrive pas à nous
ils n'ont même pas peur
mais c'est oui donc à temps il veut du
coup il veut repartir angers7
on va devoir sans wayne n'a pas le choix
et on voit qu'ils sont de plus en plus
en coin mais n'ont laissé à son actif
cette finale comme il l'a jouée à
tijuana oui il en faut des coûts pour
gagner une partie mais ouais on va
arriver à un coût en fait le noir ont
plus de coups à prendre une colonie ou
être vous et moi j'attends il ya
peut-être une idée marrante de pas très
bon je suis pas trop comment y arriver
mais genre ça ce serait pâtes sont pas
échec et non plus du tout bon faudrait
aider peux te dire déjà que côté
européen ces nanas zag needs et qui va
rentrer pour la hongrie où on se bat
alors attends je vais essayer de voir ça
alors il semble que les vols soient de
nouveau titulaire maxime et nana et je
ne sais pas encore qui sera le le
quatrième mois vient pas en sortir du
lot j'aime bien comme ça une décision
étrange un mari gilles vaillancourt g6
maintenant c est en fait le problème dès
lors c'est que ça n'ouvre le feu
boubacar objet d un coup donc bouger le
cavalier sa seule pièce quart d'heure de
jeu et où qu'il aille il est pris c'est
fini c'est gagné donc ça veut dire
victoire non pas salir victoire de la
chine contre la sélection du monde et
deux mètres et d'un autre rencontre de
match comme quoi et il a fini home sur
le baratin visite vos joueurs qui l'est
ce qui laisse fabiano mater c'est top
c'est bien c'est vrai que tout le monde
abandonne avant mais gentil amat c'est
bien qu'on voit battre au public oui oui
oui ça c'est ça c'est sympa qu'ils
soient qui sont allés jusqu'au match
mais bref un bien donc il y aura 1119 où
elle a gagné
il y aura mis le temps mais laura brown
lui qui sauve son équipe
du coup donc la chine en tête seule
équipe à avoir gagné une première ronde
et donc quatre équipes qui se tiennent
dans un mouchoir de poche juste derrière
et l'équipe du reste du monde pour
l'instant dernière mais qui a pas pris
non plus trop en fait c'est par courrier
3 mais c'était assez serré c'était serré
cette façon tous les matches on sait
rien non mais sûrement que l'équipe du
reste du monde c'est un point fort je
les vois pas se qualifier mais ils vont
prendre des points par ci par là et
quand tu veut se qualifier vaut mieux
pas trop les 100 autres à ça va être le
gros test pour la sélection européenne
ça va être le gros test pour la
sélection européenne face à la chine
elle a donc dès la prochaine partie donc
dans un petit quart d'heure en patois
mais ça va être ça va être tendu très
tendu
je ne sens pas favoris il va falloir
aller prendre les points où ils
s'offrent à nous mais j'aime bien le
choix de la titularisation de nana
designs et au quatrième et chic et c'est
une joueuse tout rien elle peut être en
grande forme et tout casser sur son
passage elle peut parfois être
en méforme et complètement sombré dans
certains tournois et c'est vrai que ça
peut être intéressant face à une joue à
jun wu yi fan d'avoir une joueuse comme
ça quitte ou double bah oui enfin
va-t-il enfin leur forme comme non sens
verrait peut être mettre le point contre
contre contre la joueuse chinoise
non mais en plus tu peux avoir fait on
sait qu'on pourra pas en avant celui
d'hier la deuxième partie tu vas jouer
tu auras les blancs tu vas me ressemble
à un jeu un contre où il fane prépare
toi bien oui donc là il ferait ch pour
cette partie a eu plusieurs jours
d'entraînement avant spécifiquement le
plan alors tu mettrais qui toi chez les
chez les mx tu mettrais a dû sortir et
les vannes tu sortir et faire ce jeu
soit sera bonne ce soir personne et les
bonnes juments racines angle de vue ça
se fait chambrer ça devient donc si les
bonnes te dit je veux jouer la deuxième
tu laisses ça je joue tu laisses es tu
là et puis voilà tu m'as senti owen on
met pas raison j'en ai fait j'aurais
fait comme toi en fait j'aurais fait
comme toi et maxime je pense que je
l'aurais jamais fait sortir il me madam
sortir un joueur d'un tel calibre que
maxime vachier lagrave bas sinon mon
effort si les creux si je ne sais pas
quoi oui mais là bas qu'il attend de
très spécial en de méforme il a fait sa
partie très normalement pique je suis
une partie de jeu et quads ans il est
crevé à première vue mais tu peux tu
peux jamais tu peux tu peux tu peux
peut-être le faire sortir sur un match
mais je sais même pas quand mais
vraiment pas si dit qu'il est fatigué
mais sinon tu peux pas sortir maxime il
est vraiment au dessus des autres maxime
vachier lagrave dans cette sélection
sans vouloir manquer de respect aux
autres joueurs
mais c'est quand même un joueur qui a
pris une dimension incroyable depuis
deux ans et il sort d'une grosse saison
d'une grosse performance au candidat et
ça me paraîtrait complètement fou de ne
pas titulariser deux joueurs français au
premier échiquier
ouais donc là un clin donc l'équipe
européenne qui aura bien du mal à se
passer des services
de notre de notre coq charles activa qui
va emmener l'équipe
alors est-ce que les composent sont
sortis tu vois je suis toujours dans
l'expectative marche
j'aime bien le côté oui je suis toujours
là non pour l'instant il n'ya pas les
compos sûr il n'ya pas les compos ouais
mais guiry je ferai jamais rentrée non
plus fait l'essai l'impression que tu
peux faire à part faire tourner à guider
et mouz hitchock ce qui me paraît
intéressant ce que tu peux prévoir un
peu en avance et et faire un peu tourner
également que sa guise et six analysés
commence à gagner une deux parties tu la
laisses août en fait après parce que
peut-être ben tu la mets à la place de
de l'époque du matériau non écoute je
sais c'est dur à dire on sait pas trop
la forme des joueurs et une partie de
jouer ça sont tous partis à de grandes
conclusions après après une partie je
vois une partie jouée vite et bien mais
non mais pour l'instant je pense guy
rentrera tôt ou tard quand même dans
cette équipe ça fera du bien des fois de
sortir et quand je dis il a cité à la
pièce de vie dit être heureux de la
prochaine a joué 115 coude a défendu
quand un food a fini par perdre on peu
déçu tu as dix minutes pour souffler
pour que tu rejoues donc la savoie est
le cas de n'importe qui et même un
maximum sa place à rennes on maigrit va
il va être solide mais aurait peut-être
à la place de les voir rester aussi une
question est-ce que tu devais
titulariser guéri et mettre les bonnes
sur le banc de bazin je veux dire par là
remplaçants non mais les vols
normalement si j'ai fait jouer s'était
longtemps numéro deux mondial un joueur
d'exception mais il a un peu reculé au
classement mais de retour de ce 10e
place mondiale
c'est
ils ont 7 mondial j'ai fait des petites
notes donc
écoute il est très légitime dans cette
compo en tant qu' en tant que titulaire
ouais ouais ouais non non il est
légitime il est légitime il est légitime
ça c'est ça c'est sûr je suis un petit
peu inquiété je vois alors pris un petit
peu inquiet en fait je vois tu sais sur
l'écran je vois les et l'écran des
arbitres en fait pour récupérer les
caméras et je crois que natalie zea pas
la meilleure connexion internet du monde
tu as peur que cela se déconnecter ou je
ne sais quoi jours inquiète toujours
inquiet sur internet ces histoires de
connexion après avec 10 secondes par
coup ça peut éviter de perdre autant à
la fin parce que donc bien sûr en termes
de cadence les ordinateurs ont le choix
son jour ce qu'on appelle en chaos dont
andrew donne une minute deux minutes
cinq minutes 10 minutes 30 minutes ce
que vous voulez ça a décidé et 0 rajoute
donc à la fin même si c'est complètement
gagnant la position mais que vous avez
dépassé votre temps de réflexion à
partie c'est fini vous avez perdu
et là la différence c'est qu'avec ce
petit rajout non vous n'avez pas perdre
tandis qu'un surtout pour le genre ce
niveau 10 secondes pour jouer un coup il
y longtemps et donc même sauvé un petit
lac avec internet ou quoi ça peut éviter
un drame de perdre comme ça oui
normalement il doit pas y avoir de
drames avec cette cadence mais bon ça
peut déconcentrer
ça peut ça peut un peu faire sortir de
la partie non mais si tu commences que
tu vois que ça rame neuf pages ou un
coutume city connections tu dois revenir
de faire enrager et apprêtée énervé plus
trop lucide et tout ça tu peux craquer
et donc j'ai rater retourne toujours pas
qui sera titulaire est ce que ce sera
tout ça est ce que ce sera guérie
peut-être que les compos n'ont pas été
données au complet cette qui gardent
garry kasparov garde peut-être le tout
afin d'être une compo dans la poche
droite une thrombose
je pense qu'ils vont en face à celle là
ouais c'est que pour le moment il n'ya
que ces trois genres la connecter alors
peut-être qu'il garde le joker stade il
a joué lui même est ce qu'il a le droit
d'ailleurs tu n'aimes pas la fin on si
si ça commence à perdre de partout à mon
avis on donnait oui pour moi je fais
quoi je dois sauver mon équipe je n'ai
pas un oligarque
oui bah qui joue plus calmes depuis 2005
ça commence à faire un petit moment
ouais alors il avait rejoué des petits
tournois d'exhibition même un grand chef
sourds qui était en tournée officielle
mais c'est plus gary d'antan n'en fit à
son c'té official c'est des parties
rapides sur deux jours puis il a pas
d'entraînement avant mais on voit que si
j'ai un mal il peut piquer mais je suis
sûr en plus que cette compétition en
tant que sélectionneur il apprend
sérieux non mais il peut pas faire
autrement
le problème c'est cuit large page ou
amicales ça m'a complètement amical non
plus un mais lui c'est sûr que non mais
je veux dire il peut pas prendre en soit
présent les ennuis c'est honorifique que
je sois là mais je mets mon nom pour la
compétition non c'est pas ça mais que
saint louis normandin a battu sent déjà
le changement à une compo quatrième je
suis sûr que c'était réfléchi déjà
depuis deux trois jours il a dû utiliser
toutes les compos tu prépares contre 1
pen tu fais c'est sûr mais même maxime
entame idéale et d4 il a dit je suis sûr
qu'ils gagnent toujours pas soit je fais
attention attention à ce que tu vas
jouer je ne te dis pas quand je vais au
premier coup mais fait même très
attention à ce que tu vas faire ça je
pense que s'il avait joué des quatre il
serait sorti dès le 2e à tuer d avoir
une troisième poche en fait un faux pas
je suis une poche de poche 3 celui où
maxime giudecca tu seras plus jamais
titulaire dans cette équipe
non mais c'est sûr que kasparov s'est
c'est quelqu'un qui peut te transcender
un bout de
tilly b mais vu les joueurs leur classe
non l'ange dans sa note
c'est un peu comme un éleveur cup contre
john barch sur le banc mcenroe
ouais je ne tenais pas quoi jouer et si
tu foutais 4 tu ne joues plus là mais
ouais c'est un petit peu ça tu fais ce
que tu veux mais si tu ne fais pas le
quatrième jouera plus jamais at war
n'attendons pas le seul choix pas le
choix tu peux jouer tu peux de pajot et
quatre non mais c'est bien ça c'est bien
ça ouais c'est gary axe que tu veux
c'est gary d'ailleurs je suis en train
de voir que sur sur le petit article
l'équipe ils ont irrigué riant et il a
eu un article légumes l'expo explorer je
pense oui mais même là pour pour la
retransmission ils ont mis gary en tête
d'affiché
non mais guys justement quelque chose
comme un jeu d'échecs gens n'ont aucune
force genre de l'histoire
après ça s'est beaucoup de chacun de
décider sur son avis c'est dur de
comparer les époques mais médiatiquement
site a un nom est cité aux échecs
tu vois dans la rue tu demandes j'aime
ça fait 15 ans qu'il a pas joué peu
importe les gens connaissent quoi comme
si stéphanie relief qui est aussi plus
difficilement visible du côté de
saint-etienne nom au jeu trop de monde
peut-être peut-être et encore tu le
régime ils font vers 1 pour te faire
plaisir mais j'ai vu merci j'avais une
fonds vert il ya beaucoup de streamer
qui cherche à me faire plaisir de cobain
ouais ouais même la météo sont là c'est
pas pour rien que le fond en hiver donc
la partie qui devrait débuter
normalement à 45 officiellement après ça
comment c'est un tout petit peu en
retard s'imaginent que c'était c'était
prévu entre guillemets on va voir ce
qu'il en est est ce que oui du coup ce
qui est prévu c'est de reprendre à 45
pile où ils ont dit bon on va essayer de
penser à 45 moi être un petit délai au
cas où il ya une partie qui suis super
tard comme il ya eu un peu le cas ici
entre caranavi dit ouais alors super
tard mais quand même
bien car dix minutes de repos ce qui me
paraît suffisant fab non je pense
la seule chose c'est peut-être comme il
ya eu du retard 5 6 minutes de retard à
la première peut-être que le retard sera
gardée alors après comme je les aime
retard vis de fer dans le sang c'était
la première ronde il devait y avoir
réussi à un côté 1 cérémonie d'ouverture
coup d'envoi et je peux annoncer
l'équipe européenne puisque c'est à nice
guy qui sera titulaire à la main de duda
alors les deux choix étonnant que kaspar
enfin ouais c'est vrai que coûte mais
alors peut-être que pour les styles ou
et ihealth est pas un il me semblait
tout à intéressant personnellement mais
peut-être gearing prépare aussi
oui tu peux de 9 cas de figure que pour
pour ce qu'on disait que madame jeannine
z
en fait tu y vas tu veux le deuxième
match prépare toi alors on va voir aussi
un la compo des joueurs chinois les
chinois qui ont fait tourner tout comme
nous qui font jouer du lion guillot 3 et
qui titularisé à la surprise générale
quand même joué john logan est bon
qu'ils allaient surprise contre surprise
donc ils te laissent pas respirer quoi
les chinois net 18 j'avais lu hitler en
ton jeu ouais le préparer contre mon nom
maintenant ça ne va pas marcher
intéressant les deux les deux deux
entraîneurs de sélectionneur si on qui
ont fait un des choix miroir et donc du
coup maxime et gillian s'apprendre
premier échiquier
ils ont déjà joué la première ronde oui
à rognan aussi et donc de ski et 3 et 4
avec des joueurs frais ouais ça a tourné
de cette manière là et je vais te dire
que ça va être chaud de chez shaw je
vois bien une partie nulle ou troisième
échiquier entre young est guérie deux
joueurs très solides
oui échiquier de lemon a scellé vonn
s'est pas oui qui est sorti c'est pas
oui qui est sorti fab
non non c'est mon gars c'est ou en garde
donc pas une stratégie de miroirs en
réalité ils ont fait sortir le 2 mai oui
ça ils ont fait sortir le 2 donc les 20
noeuds contre voyez elle est bonne les
22 août sûrs et ce que je voulais dire
aussi j'avais vu dans les règles c'est
que tout est en place on ne peut que
rentrer échiquier numéro 3 eyes in fx
est chic et là un peu comme dans les
halls
ah non
les olympiades ça marche pas quand tu en
fait humide enfin tu fais ta liste de
cinq joueurs qui devront être toujours
dans ce rôle donc le 1 sera toujours au
moins on ne sera pas là et le 2 3 soit
aux deux soit silhouette voilà au 1
donc ton mec numéro cinq sur la liste
mais soit ils en tribunes soient aussi
joué de jeter numéro 4 voilà mais c'est
toujours dans l'arbre tu peux pas dire à
triturer héros une fois en bas après
c'est définissez défini moi je suis sur
le papier ce match europe chine
il se joue à rien ça tu es dans un
mouchoir de poche très équilibré et
peut-être que level même je pense que
les européens un peu favorable coûte
j'espère tu vois je vois bien une de mes
menus et les victoires des bottes ça va
jouer s'arrête la guerre partout de
toute façon digne qui va forcément
essayer contre maxime il aura les blancs
là je pense qu'un des ruines et rassure
les anons n'ya pas d'avoir sur les
couleurs ce que c'est l'europe oui on
joue on joue à je m'étais fait la
remarque en regardant les affiches vous
jouer deux fois avec les blancs aux
premiers pas mal roulé blanc un accord
et blanc au premier bilan mais du coup
les choses parce que c'était digne blanc
contre maxime les votes blancs
ok ça change de ce truc c'est pour ça
que je trouve assez étrange de la
titularisation de guiry aux trois tout
avec les blancs j'aurais bien aimé
laisser personnellement après
c'est un choix qui a été fait par par
kasparov difficile sur les critiques et
j'ai envie de te dire ou alors tu as
kasparov sur la cam allez viens on va
aimer alors attends à une petite seconde
les gars pour que je vous met les calmes
le discours d'avant match attend la
petite causerie attendait alors attendez
la parole
ouais mais cela ne se lève oui mais bon
on va essayer de relever on l'a vu se
lever quoi on allait attenter s'il
revient je laisse sur la caméra pour
qu'on ne rate pas sisi reviens je t'en
on voit la chaise de kasparov quoi même
sans messi revient je remets non mais
c'était marrant mais était avec ses
petites lunettes en train de tuchan têtu
et ses petits papiers
ces démarches auprès note tous ont la
gale envie de voir gary c est pour
mettre un coup de pression à l'équipe
d'europe
cherchez pas il s'est levé kouame
kasparov légende vivante des et chacun
comme tu le disais il reste encore
aujourd'hui le joueur le plus connu au
monde
bah en fait il a juste entre guillemets
a été numéro un mondial 20 ans d'affilée
il est champion du monde cette fois
c'est au fond des filets elle y revient
à les enlever la caméra on aurait une
seconde de 4 à 9
on aura eu une seconde de kasparov fab
et c'est déjà pas mal
en train de me perdre complètement dans
les calmes
ouais
j'ai un bug total sur les calmes
tant qu'on allait juger juste que je
réussisse à faire venir ça il n'a pas la
caméra mais oui en fait il a il est venu
il a enlevé sa caméra et là je ne peux
pas écouter ce qu'ils disent mais il est
en train de parler à l'équipe
non je vois je vois que c'est lui qui
est en train de parler je vois que c'est
lui qui en train de parler
elle aurait pu faire son discours avec
la madrague gauche dans la caméra
j'aurais fiche à temps désolé fa pour ce
petit souci gens prennent parfois qui
j'imagine que c'est pas pour ça donc bon
vieux codes sociaux n'est pas vraiment
de mon fait sa tête
je vais peut-être faire différemment ce
que j'avais fait au début ça me
demandait une petite petite technique
regarde si les partis ont pas commencé
l'ère je les vois pas - démarré que des
parties son parti aura très jeune alors
c'est peut-être le départ ce qui serait
de 1 mais pour l'instant ça va c'est
toujours en pause
je pense à pas trop trop tard et pour le
coup mais ça à temps quand ça attend
encore
ça c'est essayer de choper garicoix qui
fait prendre le risque du bac c'est
comme s'il voulait te punir oui je
voulais pas que la caméra s'ouvre j'ai
fait bugger l'ordinateur de 7,6 du jour
mais la cam de maxime du goût qui est de
retour il est prêt nina starting blocks
ouais très focus très concentré il a mis
un peu la même chose que moi oui c'est
assorti
il sera assorti et il est la fab le voir
français échiquier numéro un de l'équipe
européenne qui représente nos couleurs
au plus haut niveau mondial à fab
alors au nom de qui capitaine de la
russie alors là aussi c'est mo ti
l'affluence n'a qui est très bon grand
maître pareil qui joue plus
puis si souvent que ça mais mais qui a
été top 100 mondial je pense
le prince william qui est un entraîneur
slash sélectionneur emblématique des
équipes russes
voilà c'est le réputé c'est à dire qu'il
est il est temps l'entourage du haut
niveau russe depuis un moment il a été
je crois seconde ans ou dans l'équipe de
karuïa keane qui a été le dernier rue ça
disait la couronne mondiale finalement
dans ce match contre carole scène et ils
travaillent
ils travaillent dans les camps
d'entraînement avec les équipes russes
j'avais eu la chance fab de me trouver à
juste en face du serveur avec toutes les
préparations de l'équipe russe lorsque
j'étais allé au siège de la fédération
russe puisque j'ai avec les ordis ils
tendent un fonds à j'étais en face gt gt
aussi proches que l'écran de mon ordi de
l'immense serveurs avec toutes les
préparations de toutes les équipes
russes et jolie petite clé usb un petit
truc dans dire je peux te dire que
c'était impressionnant c'est c'est une
vraie pièce qui doivent est plus grande
que mon studio
là où je suis en train d'enregistrer et
avec des climatisation tournent à fond
face et et sécuriser un hyper sécurisé
il ya une porte à clé pour avoir la clé
il faut que tu ailles demandé à la
sécurité qui à l'entrée du bâtiment
c'est eux qui ont la clé qui la donne
voilà comme j'ai un bon ami comme j'ai
vécu longtemps en russie m'avait il
m'avait ouvert ma vidéo tiens je te
montre ça parce que c'est c'est le nerf
de la guerre tu vois mais il ya cette
fameuse pièce dans ce bâtiment avec
toutes les prépare us et motivés qui
depuis un moment voilà tourner dans cet
entourage et qui fait partie des
entraîneurs et sélectionneurs russe
serait péter pham quelqu'un au chat ou
grandes qui comprend pas trop ces
histoires de préparation comment est-ce
que tu peux savoir ce que l'adversaire
va jouer une ou deux banques
alors ça toi nous raconte de répondre
voilà est bon en fait c'est juste
comment dire tu fais tu regardes ce
qu'il ya déjà joué
ils disent hey de tirer des sortes de
probabilité n'est jamais sûr en fait de
ce qu'il va jouer un peu de jeu tout et
n'importe quoi mais si tu as quelqu'un
qui lors des 30 dernières parties à
jouer toujours de la même manière il ya
de grosses chances que la 31e lire joue
encore comme ça donc tu regarde un peu
ce conte historique le genre position
dès qu'il ya des bons résultats des
mauvais résultats ce qui pourrait devoir
changer et une fragilité à un moment et
avec tous ces indices tu essaies d'en
déduire les choses donc c'est plus de la
déduction que de vue de la révision est
tué 1 8%
c'est toute façon des fois t'es sûr de
rien tu dire hier qu'elle joue sa tête
tout ça est donc un joueur plus il joue
autre chose d'ailleurs pluie rend
difficile la préparation contre lui
mais après bien évidemment c'est pas si
simple de jouer plusieurs variantes ça
demande beaucoup plus de mémorisation et
de travail c'est peut-être plus
d'être expert d'une manière de jouer et
d'une ligne de jeunes problème c'est que
tu vas être ciblée est un ado qui
prennent l'autre stratégie d'apprendre
beaucoup et un peu de riz blé est
peut-être un peu moins experts quelque
part voilà pour donner un exemple
concret le numéro un français maxime
vachier lagrave c'est un joueur lui qui
peut être ciblés et je vous des
ouvertures tout le monde c'est steve ou
contre quatre il joue ses cinq une
sicilienne contre des quatre jours une
ouverture qu'on appelle la grüne feld il
ne change quasiment jamais donc il est
ciblé mais il en est le meilleur
spécialiste mondial donc il part du
principe que même si les cibler c'est
pas grave
viens viens me chercher c'est du béton
armé quoi ouais bah en fait ça montre
aussi tu as confiance que finalement si
tu as peur d'un mec qui va se préparer
une fois spécifiquement contre toi alors
toi ce fait des années que joue cette
ouverture c'est peut-être qu'il ya un
problème dans ton je sais que tu sais
qu'en fait des spécialistes
autoproclamés on va dire pas tant que ça
mais en fait d'avoir confiance dans ce
que tu fais est d'aller à l'épreuve du
feu bah c'est pas là puisque en plus au
cas où ça se passe mal mais tu apprends
quelque chose et tu vas encore mieux
améliore pas pour fois d'après donc
c'est une bonne approche sa demande
alors confiance d'avoir bien bossé ce
ouverture là et finalement il serait que
les gens qui changent souvent c'est que
justement ils vont pas trop confiance
mon répertoire principal mais peut-être
parce qu'il en a marre ils n'ont pas la
solidité pour la voir et du coup un
palmarès ils sont chargés ouverture sans
arrêt mais met donc voilà c'est ça c'est
sûr préparation pour le coup bah si tu
es dingli rennes et que tu joues comme
maxime je te dis bon ya peu de chances
qu'il joue quatre premiers coups et
voilà india on a vu dans le magazine
professionnel qui avait siégé sicilienne
l'a peut-être il va rejouer sur la
porter normal qu'ils aient eu 4 5
donc tu te dis c'était quoi l'eau des
deux derniers affrontements et donc
maxime sauvageau levante espagnol sur
ces ouvertures soit l'italienne et
j'espère avec détroit souvent le dernier
affrontement pour la peine il avait
tourné tournée
et rapidement court alors du joueur du
joueur français qui avait remporté la
partie sortie d'ouverture où l'on
compare les préparations maxime qui
avait ciblé qui avait joué aux 4,5 son
espagnol qui connaît bien il était
rentré dans une variante qu'il avait
préparée et la partie à la sortie de la
préparation était complètement gagnante
pour le français c'est c voilà le
français qui d'art fois qu'il a joué
contre dinghy rennes avait gagné sur
l'ouverture ce sera l'entrée de jeu sur
le service en fait c'est comme un
service gagnant et donc bah oui non dits
guyane doit réparer ça il doit réviser
avant la partie pendant les idées
fraîches ou alors je change de ces 5 4
voilà en gros je pense à sa réflexion
c'est à lui de voir si comme ça à chaque
année 6,6 leurs pertes dès l'ouverture
on prend un pardon j'ai dit steve leur
père dans l'ouverture à bages
on a vida patron vie quoi on ne sait pas
quand ils jouent contre une personne
dont le nom ne rentre pas à gauche
sur le papier est par ailleurs au bout
d'un moment il aurait peut-être dû
écrire le diminutif de maximin mvl way
nnomo trois lettres et nouvelles qui
s'alimentent souvent c'est un joueur qui
est tu vois c'est vraiment attention à
ça ils sont en train de boire de manger
un petit peu c'est important un jeu le
souligner pour la quatrième ou cinquième
fois du de la retransmission mais c'est
important ça dépend ce que tu manges
ça dépend ce que tu manges jour pareil
mais c'est important
maxime qui est bien qui est chaud qui
est souriant qui a l'air confiant il a
de nouveau les blancs il sait que c'est
un match important ça peut déjà être un
premier tournant de la compétition
mini tournant exactement c'est vrai que
tu veux à la chine mais bien qu'elles
seront meilleures journées 1.51 et demi
sur eux contre la russie et la chine
ouais ouais non clairement
j'imagine qu'ils vont démarrer à 17h
j'imagine que ça va aboutir à 17 heures
l'arbitré là les joueurs sont là tout le
monde est prêt à en découdre maxime tout
sourire
il a l'air bon il aurait alors une
petite idée non on va aller maxime
allais mon poulet à l'effort ira
chercher celle là elle est importante
elle c'est vraiment un match important
l'a déjà d'entrée tu as si on perd
contre la chine il faudra faire l'effort
pour revenir
la romance enlève la pression on va
chercher le point et on reprend une
nouvelle journée demain en faisant
partie immédiatement des favoris de la
compétition
perdre contre la chine ne serait pas
rédhibitoire fab mai mais bon faudra
cravacher pour revenir après watch met
plus de pression tu tends la main joker
ses terres et c'est donc mais ces deux
gros tests
ouais c'est le gros test d'entrée match
nul contre la russie quand même un bon
résultat pour entrer dans la compétition
oui donc surtout que les états unis
n'ont pas n'ont pas battu l'inde
donc finalement y'a que la chine qui a
pris le point mais contre la sélection
présumée la plus faible donc ya pas
vraiment de pour le mans les équipes
s'observent a été jumelles oui qu'ont
fait les américains entre les indiens
pour l'audit est de croiser ce serait
pour départ au campo tures regarde pas
les parties étaient écrites et orales et
partie des autres matches oui s'ils sont
en train de faire mieux je peux faire
nul si ça serait beau quoi alors pas
trop tard mais il est 17h ouais ça
devrait repartir d'ici peu d'ici peu à
mon avis ce serait une bonne chose aussi
pour l'équipe européenne d'avoir une
belle partie de l'even l' histoire de
vraiment se relancer
me qui ceux qui se lancent qui voit là
allez hop hop hop on y va on démarre
j'essaye de chauffer les arbitres ouais
bah je sais pas ce qu ils font quoi
mais je peux te dire sur toutes les
caméras tous les joueurs sont sortis
ouais ça sent ça sent que ça va repartir
d'une seconde à l'autre la mélo kitchen
monde c'est quoi les autres matches ces
états unis contre contre contre contre
contre eux écoute je vais te le dire ce
que c'est à 06 etats unis russie et en
inde le reste du monde à las ils ont
battu sans les joueurs vraiment au
taquet quoi sur la sur la ligne de
départ
maxime aussi la team europe
allez les amis 17h01 sont en train de
partir fab c'est en train de partir il
ya les malbars je vois ça alors c'est
les autres matches les matches qui
débutent avec un tout petit tout petit
décalage déjà vu les américaines ont
fait entrer son équipe ça rigole pas
mais soit à mon avis est un titulaire en
puissance
je crois que c'est parti c'est parti
côté côté maxime et qui envoient des 4
atteints il y aurait de l'équipe
attention axim rêvait peut-être qu'il a
voulu à qui veut qui peut peut-être joué
le l'idée de jouer à long terme tu sais
pas si jour aucun tous des quatre dans
la compet peut-être évité les prépas
pour la suite
brouiller les pistes fab et donc défense
nîmes though the beach aux indiennes et
donc l'idée des noirs s'ils choisissent
ont fait une pause ou ce que qu'on aille
vendre ici on joue beaucoup de coups
rapidement fait le trou alors là juste
juste on peut souligner que après des
cas qui décèdent jouer le 4 pour m de
bureaux centres car m6 qui l'empêchent
c4 de six cavaliers ces trois ans menace
de nouveau deux ou quatre roues b4
empêche le 4 puisque lecavalier pourrait
être pris en prendrait le tueur du 4 et
dams et 2 qui vient protéger le cavalier
pour éviter de se doubler les pions et
contrôle et éventuellement aussi la case
de 4 avec la dame
le 4 est joué émanant des cinq donc
combat au centre femmes avec une
structure de type française justement
exactement se structure figée mais
l'énorme différence est que les blancs
un pion en c4 et donc de allaient
s'échanger sur des 5 ou les noirs
pourront peut-être le prendre un jour
et deuxième chose que ça change
énormément en battant la française sait
que c'est leur fond ces cinq pour
justement venir m d'énormes tensions
récentes avec quatre pions comme ça tu
as plus de points pour pouvoir défendre
conso clan des quatre donc savannah
française normalement le pense et 4 il
vient se mettre en c3 il soutient tous
les autres alors que là c'est pas le cas
il ya un énorme combat au centre femmes
avec une multitude de pièces qui
viennent jouer pour pour ces quatre
cases 1 quasiment tous les coups des
deux joueurs ont un rapport avec avec se
sentent avec cette montagne dont on
parlait lors de la première partie est
là la montagne fab
c'est c'la les places sont chères exact
mais là c'est encore très très
théoriques et les joueurs connaissent
ils sont encore en train d'improviser
il récite un peu tout ce que sont leurs
analyses à la maison en amont d'un match
4 menacé le fouet le pion à f2 g3 qui
contre-attaqué la dame qui vient h5 qui
se place là il ya peut-être un pion qui
est gagnable pour les blancs mais
j'imagine comme tu dis que c'est
théorique et ultra analyse et maxime qui
rockent mieux donc les noirs bon on voit
qui met une belle pression sur centre
mais encore faut t'il finir le
développement c'est une des difficultés
de leurs positions le fou s'est vite il
n'est pas sorti un problème récurrent et
donc ils gênent dans la foulée sa tour
inviter ses enchaînements c'est un peu
un effet domino donc il ya deux pièces
noires qui ne peuvent pour le moment pas
participer aux jeux alors que maxime il
est à deux coups on va dire de vraiment
faire participer absolument toutes ces
pièces dans la bataille ses seins puis
en plus l'aca blanc une menace aussi
peut être qu'elle prend 4 qui gagnera un
pion maintenant que karine et que vous
louez exactement donc avec les avec les
nerfs faut trouver comment réagir
normalement aussi tu as le pion aux cinq
qui traînent peut-être prendre un jour
ou l'autre
pas tout de suite je sais pas peut-être
ya du faux 2 qui te dit cette dame qui
remplit une formule cavaliers je sais
pas et jouent g5 imagine que c'est
encore théorique femme écoute je suis
pas un expert des trucs j'ai un sonar
déjà vu ça dans la vie donc je voudrais
te dire que oui mais je vais pas
m'avancer à ternat porte
donc tout est inventé c'est toujours
théorique tout cas on voit un quinze
joueurs du calibre de maxime même si
c'était pas son répertoire principale
avant des quatre très rapidement ses
joueurs sont au niveau et sont capables
de réciter de la théorie est apprendre
par coeur d'ingurgiter un nombre de
variantes là aussi impressionnant quand
on parlait des différences entre les
joueurs du temps et mondiale et les
autres on a parlé dans la première
partie de la vitesse de calcul qui est
impressionnant 6 16 chez ces joueurs là
mais leur mémoire est aussi en cyclo
pedic bahia dans une préparation d'un
d'ouverture incroyable et aussi bas faut
dire que font pas le travail tout pour
la maison tout liquide avec eux c'est à
dire que maxime est il à son entraîneur
attitré 7e bacrot donc qui a été
multiples chaînes en france je pense
qu'une fois qui a été membre du top 10
mondial qui est passive urnes et camilla
il a il a 36 37 ans et donc qui
travaillent pour lui donc tout ce qu'il
a pu apprendre mon sa vie analysé etc
il peut lui dire voilà sur animaux je
pense que ce coup là c'est pas mal et c
est donc c'est quand même une grande
règle plutôt qu situe reprend tout à
zéro et que tu veux te faire toute ta
culture tout seul et tout fouillé
cependant il faut quand même sur les
ingurgiter les variants d'aller là où
une et les retenir et ça reste ça reste
un travail incroyable et il faut en
avoir les capacités parce que ce qu'ils
apprennent c'est c'est vraiment
l'équivalent de bibliothèque de livres
non complètement comblé
et puis tu averses de trucs qui se
ressemblent déjà une petite différence
et tu passes d'une position des façons
oui puis la ceinture est maxime là qui
change le répertoire et qui même avec
son nouveau répertoire garde il a même
pas vraiment eu besoin de réfléchir
c'est à dire non seulement alors mémoire
incroyable mais ils sont capables de la
mobiliser en quelques secondes
donc en tout cas c'est les deux joueurs
qui ont l'air de savoir ce qu'ils font
tout ça ça a dû être analysés à la
maison puisque là la position est d'une
complexité incroyable et ça joue très
vite donc ça veut dire que les joueurs
connaissent et maxime qui plaît 5
je savais que quand ça se passe comme ça
c'était juste faire nul en jouant très
très vite
sa lutte après ils ont tout va si deal
de savez tous jusqu'au bout elles seront
prêtes maximy c'est ce qui fait medingo
si donc n'a pas entrer dans un truc où
il sait que ces perdants enfin ça c'est
clair
et en plus on sait que les échecs enfin
les échecs sont censés être un jeu qui
donne match nul en cas de jeu parfait
des deux joueurs
donc quand les deux joueurs récite des
préparations c'est que ce sont des
variantes 800 justement trouvé sept nuls
théorique est fondamental qui doit
arriver dans le jeu d'échecs et oui
forcément
ces deux jouent vite c'est en faveur des
noirs qui sont censé souffrir un petit
peu mais qu'il a pourrait aller chercher
un demi point de manière forcée
après bon truc c'est que un jour ou
l'autre tu peux avoir une nouvelle idée
bout qui n'a jamais dit ce n'est pas une
nouveauté théorique et prendre de court
ton adversaire après 1 général jetons
ces joueurs-là sont même prêts sur des
couples ils sont pas juste là regardez
qu'est ce qui a déjà été fait à ok je
voudrais surtout ils sont déjà pose la
question qu'est ce qui peut être
amélioré ou est-ce que ça peut être
renforcé et c'est pourquoi il appelle
les secours ici et allemands ils sont
même prêts donc voir ni contre d'autres
oui et donc toute la finesse maintenant
c'est même pas de juste rester ce que
fait le redis c'est trouver justement le
mouvement on peut un petit peu dévié et
donc jouer je mets un truc un peu
nouveau et mettre en difficulté
l'adversaire soit par un test de mémoire
soit en forçant justement à prendre une
décision par lui même sur l'échiquier et
en choisissant là où c'est peut-être le
plus piégeurs pour un homme tout seul je
le redis c'est toute une expérience
exactement c'est pas c'est pas tout
simple tas il suffit pas d'allumer leur
dit et dire ok il a dit de jouer ça je
fais ça c'est fait il ya toute une
démarche derrière bien sûr et c'est pas
facile
il ya des joueurs qui sont reconvertis
en étant d'excellents préparateur
justement parce qu'ils ont cette
finissent là ouais non c'est une science
particulière qui s'est pas forcément les
meilleurs joueurs qui sont les meilleurs
pour ça alors les meilleurs mondiaux
sont forcément fort pour faire ça mais
c'est pas forcément les gens les plus
originaux on connaît par exemple daniel
du boeuf
l'époque où un jeune homme qui travaille
dans l'équipe de magnus carlsen et qui
apportent des idées très originales et
très piégeuse
alors c'est un excellent joueur il va
faire partie du top 40 mondial je pense
top 50 mais c'est pas un joueur du top
10 mondial en revanche au niveau des
préparations et d'originalité c'est
peut-être le meilleur tout simplement
nous avons en tout cas fait partie des
meilleurs et c'est vrai qu'avoir un
joueur comme ça dans son équipe un
entraîneur comme ça dans son équipe
ça peut rapporter de temps en temps des
points et faire la différence
bah c'est super si tu peux avoir une
équipe d'entraîneurs varié avec chacun
des compétences ça m'est très sérieux
qui sait très bien faire des ordinateurs
qui va tout bien vérifier un mec créatif
qui a des idées humaine mais qui est
justement un tuyau au feu de
l'ordinateur et à vérifier ça parce que
ça peut être temps table parce que c'est
pas trop dur de l'autre en pratique et
c'était donc faut prendre celui de fou
prend des quatre jouer il va sûrement y
avoir une prise en vaisselle j'imagine
une reprise en 5 et peut-être un coup
droit j'ai deux pour essayer de faire
naviguer la tour vers agen les blancs
sont sensiblement mieux tout de même
femme
il ya un peu plus de solidité au tour du
roi blanc avec un seul îlot thion et des
pions qui se protège et peut-être une
petite idée pour jouer sur case blanche
donc il ya quand même une position
avantageuse pour maxime vachier lagrave
mais légèrement mes jambes parce que
donc il ya la présence des fous de
couleurs opposées en cas d' échange
massif de pièces on a réparé dans la
partie d'avant en fait si vous vous
souvenez bien entre entre visiter
caruana on disait que ce footeux
défendre ses pions claude tchou propre
attaqué par contre tant qu'il ya
d'autres pièces encore présente
évidemment davantage c'est ça aide le
camp qu'il va attaquer parce que du coup
la lame et loulou se connecter pour
attaquer un pion adverse ou une case
adverse et le fou noir des noirs par
exemple pourrait pas intervenir avant sa
détention qui l'a par exemple si le
fouillant le cadre pour pour schématiser
attaqué le pion à vii et noir pourrait
défendre avec leur tour lors d'art où le
roi mais me fous des cas tu ne pourras
jamais attaqué à
défendre s'être autant que le fou j'ai
deux pourra jamais défendre le pion à f2
exactement
donc ça c'est important d'essayer de
prendre l'initiative dans ce cas les
[ __ ] que leur oppose et après tu peux
essayer donc de blindés avec les noirs
d'essayer de voir schématiquement
coiffeur et c'est peut-être dans l'idéal
ce serait de ramener le fou des quatre
ans g7 et tout l'est m le pion à 6 comme
ça il se dit le défendrai et évacuer la
tour pouvoir soit une case office pour
le voir elles sont là sûrement tout
vient solidifier
mais il en est loin mais également parce
que sur fou prend le sens que je pense
qu'il ya déjà de l'argent avec un
problème sur 1 600 d'hommes g6 peut-être
fou c'est à lire un petit entrepreneur
salarié dame ces six échecs heureusement
est donc déjà renée supprimerait les
dames ce qui enlève ce potentiel d'attac
et ok là pour le coup ça ferait nul
ouais c'est un bon exemple de ce que les
blancs ne voudrais pas entre guillemets
parce que s'il a plus assez de matériel
on ne réussira pas à faire la différence
donc il a appris en baisse il a pris en
5 et prix en baisse est donc le fou mais
ça qui est bien parce qu'il empêche tout
échec
il est propriétaire de la diagonale donc
il défend son roi et de se ramener en
leucate pour exercer une pression avec
la dame en direction de roanne ce petit
avantage blanc qui doit pas être
suffisant pour gagner mais il faudra
encore un jeu parfait côté chinois
ouais c'est ça peut être agréable en
fait d'avoir la planche dans situation
parce que si tu n'y arrives pas aux
pierres ya nul n'y a pas de risque et
puis bastille l'adversaire défend pas
hyper bien battus à le faire souffrir et
gagner donc c'est du jeu je m'appelle
joie de résultats donc il pourrait
arriver demain
alors on va essayer à d'aller voir
aniche guiry donc le nouvel entrant côté
européen qui est opposé à yu yang y donc
comme tu disais c'est un joueur qui
avait fait une belle saison 2009 début
de saison surtout à vendin peut
s'écrouler
il était rentré dans le top 10 mondial
et
il est redescendu ouais il est pas resté
longtemps mais comme toujours très
solide et d'ailleurs on voit ce qu'ils
jouent là il te fait une position quasi
symétriques c'était issu d'une défense
petrov en forme entraînée jusque là où
j'en étais le mas d'en accélérer un pur
pas sur le direct ou indirect mango bon
c'est s'ajouter un truc symétrique alors
c'est la spécialité des chinois cette
ouverture là l'ouverture russes aussi à
mékhé la spécialité des joueurs chinois
il y en a beaucoup qui joue sa etc
c'est très solide parce que tout ce qui
est asymétrique justement n'y a pas de
conflit d équilibre trop rapide et on
voit reste avec le même genre pierse et
on a tous deux tours chacun une dame
chacun deux cavaliers un fou il ya eu
des changements je suis content
cavaliers ou quoi et les pions sont
quasiment tous en phase est juste le
petit pion dans le droit qu'a lancée
pour les noirs tout cas qui sont
toujours assez symétrique ouais c'est
très solide et on voit que le conflit
centrale il est il est aussi un petit
peu gelé quoi ya pas de consignes qu'ils
fassent donc pas facile et les blancs
qui aurait bien aimé prendre possession
de la case 5
mais pas facile parce qu'il avait essayé
il a monté sa tour d'un cran ça peut
permettre à leur tour de passer derrière
ils sont fait doubler les tours il
échangera sûrement mais le tour alors
qu'elle vient à temps mais elle est
largement les différents de tout échange
est géré par midam ans il fut adapté du
roi pour passer le tour juste à côté
ensuite et un millier complètement 6
passes une stratégie de luang et noir de
vraiment jouer pour faire match nul ne
cherche pas du tout à prendre de risque
qui dirige doit en rien du tout mais ça
arrive souvent en fait toujours avec les
noirs dit ok donc tu commences ça toi de
faire quelque chose et si ya nulle
bassin moins important alors on va aller
voir levern aronian qui lui faisait
défaut une défense russe mais oui à la
met plus de velléités que plus de plus
de danger que gears y un joueur solide
aussi un donc c'est un peu de glace
contre glace la wei qui décident
volontairement 2
de faire un déséquilibre dans la
position pour donner du jeu exactement
il joua que déjà les recomposer les
blancs font drogue marty roth donc ça ça
donne tout chuter un clash voire plus
violent parce que on peut envoyer les
pions comme le fait le fond les blancs
là en puissance thion h
ça va pas affaiblir le roi qui serait
derrière il est plus un peu donc on peut
envoyer les pions en première ligne
allait créer des conflits des échanges
ouverts des lignes ont pas de salut tu
sais qui est des échanges se passent et
du coup le roi adverse
fred-lille et il n'aurait plus trop
garde devant une protection et là on
s'engouffre
cependant il a un gros tard autant oui
il a déjà dépensé dix minutes contre à
peine une et quelques contres les vonn
qui doit s'y joue aussi vite savoir très
précisément ce qu'il est en train de
faire et peut-être qu'en voulant créer
un déséquilibre il est tombé dans pas
dans le piège mais il est peut-être
tombé dans la préparation du joueur
arménien en partie rapide ça peut vite
mal se passer
mais pour la pendule cheval frère c'est
que j'ai vu que les vannes avait joué
vite la partie d'avant aussi et cette
pente pêcher le mauvais résultats donc
est ce qu'ils connaissent que justin
joue vite parce que ça lui semble de
toute façon des coûts très logique
alors il a mis deux minutes 09 avec les
noirs pour jouer cavalier c5 donc le
dernier coup il a vraiment pris le temps
de jeter leur soin de peser le pour le
pour et le contre et on va aller voir la
dernière partie avec jouer double jeu
avec les pièces blanches catalan on va
passer d'un qe 3 g 3 803 pas une 4 vers
turquie avait été jouée pour la première
fois lors d'un tournoi barcelone je
crois d'où son nom
chassez tartakowsky ouimette le fou
angers dans les très mal sa tablette
bah oui mais là j'ai bien aimé la
manoeuvre de la joueuse géorgienne ouais
deux places et se fout pas mal placé
l'aixois renfermer des réceptions et
elle les a passé deux mois donc au loup
qui tape sur rien si ces projets soient
limités et lui a donné la vie
mission tout à fait correct pour pur
nanar c'est vrai qu'il faut il ya deux
joueurs de joueurs du caucase dans cette
équipe européenne sont titulaires là les
bonnes et nana na na donc on retourne
chez la bête le 'lion' beast c'est son
pseudo sur internet et sur internet
maxime vachier lagrave et on voit dingli
rennes qui essayent de s'activer
peut-être amené une tour en b2 pour
commencer à jouer de concert sur le pion
sur le put rêve de fab
en fait ce qui aurait bien en faisant
soir c'est que ça à la fois s'activera
sept jours ou lequel va signer à côté du
roi elle joue elle rend dans le camp
adverse et ça rendrait passible à tour
des blancs parce que elle devrait
défendre le petit pion ici parce que ben
il y aurait la tour et le fou qui
avaient tous les deux donc c'est très
utile en fait non retour à la fois
activée de pacifier la tourada pacifié
d'ailleurs avec les deux orthographes je
sais pas se dire oui en fait on pourrait
penser que tu veux dire pacifiée dans le
dans le dans le sens rendre passif mais
aussi pacifiée dans le cycle haussier
des rampes passif le sens premier jeu
vous l'utilisez les deux sens marche
donc j'espère qu'un des deux mois existe
au moins mais du coup bas sous faut bien
choisir avec les membres et j'ai peur
que comme tu le dis c'est gênant quand
ça joue vite des deux côtés on espérait
un petit quelque chose pour les blancs
mais 5 6 a été archi analysées par le
parti guirane le jour avec les noix
généralement ils connaissent le bon plan
souvent des positions un peu difficile
comme ça il ya un plan qui va être qui
va être vraiment fort pour pour égaliser
c'est très difficile de trouver
lorsqu'on est sur l'échiquier
mais lorsqu'on connaît parfois ces
policiers un peu difficile à peuvent
devenir assez simple à jouer
je sais en hauteur c'est toujours plus
sympa vous savez à quoi tu as la
difficulté c'est de le rendre
concrètement possible mais si tu as ton
fils directeur après t'as plus qu'à
calculer et comment je fais pour ramener
cette pièce ici bon bah c'est juste les
habitudes calcul qui montre en jaune
mais mais c'est déjà une grande hâte de
savoir où aller parce que c'est un
problème aux échecs situe mais quelqu'un
devant une position au début
partout c'est pas quelques poussées si
on commence avait expliqué c'est
important de prendre le centre de
développer cash et on aura beau faire
des choses comme ça ça va être d'autant
plus simple de trouver les bons coups
j'ai peut-être pas tout faire parfait
mais ça va t'aider bout je dirais que
c'est un petit peu déjà aux échecs tu as
peut-être de deux choses quand tu as une
position déjà formulé la question la
position je sais pas si on peut appeler
ça comme ça hein toute position est
problématique
mais un problème donc déjà connaître le
problème de sa position c'est déjà un
premier pas ensuite il ya parfois une
réponse pour y répondre une manière de
répondre au problème de régler le
problème
parfois il peut y avoir plusieurs
réponses et on a du mal à savoir
laquelle est la bonne et il arrive
souvent dans les positions difficiles
dont on parle avec fabien qui est 3,4
manière de régler le problème est que
concrètement seulement une de ses
manières marche
mais si on connaît on a vu on sait
quelle manière est censé marché parce
qu'on l'a analysé c'est vrai que ça
facilite quand même la tâche
enfin madame est téléguidée et donc
voilà aussi d'activer la tour c'est un
bien logique de satin rouge en chine et
je voulais dire pour le court et il
attaque pas à m'en fous mais on peut le
montrer parce que citoyen fouilles adams
et lutter chef de l'attak a tapé trois
tacles à tour donc comme dame nature
droit le prioritaire chauffe ou français
me paraît sain et donc n'aurait perdu
notre tour est un gros avantage lente
sur mon bic gagnant donc
donc voilà maxime en fait qui négligent
la menace qui en fait n'en est pas une
pour basson tour activer sa tour et
c'est de prendre de vitesse son
adversaire
donc là il menace quand même le pion à
chaptelat près du rhin et tu vois dans
les coûts et dans l'est dans les
décisions difficiles à prendre et sur
pareil si tu sais tu es analyse avec
l'ordinateur c'est plus facile chez toi
est-ce qu'il faut jouer h5
c'est à dire ce qu'il fait très
rapidement je refais ouais mais je veux
dire dans le sens où si on a déjà
analysé la position qu'on sait que c'est
pas trop grave d'avancé pions parce que
c'est quand même un pion aux tic par
vers l'avant nom qui peut qui peut
manquer à la défense du roi mais si vous
avez analysé vous avez vu dans beaucoup
de cas de figure le h5 et est un bon
coup bas dans ces cas là toujours pareil
vous devrez vous aurez moins
d'hésitation il sera plus facile à jouer
et ça ça facilite grandement la tâche on
se répète un peu mais c'est pour bien
bien comprendre ce que c'est quand même
hyper important aux échecs
cette histoire d' analyse à présent fab
vu que les ordinateurs ont pris une
importance considérable depuis deux
décennies maintenant la cbi talent très
vite a donc le temps c'est vrai que ça a
révolutionné l approche d'ouverture
c'est devenu plus scientifique encore
qu'avant on déjà qu'avant ça rigolait
pas mais rien que la vitesse de
circulation de l'information et d'un an
changé avec l'apparition d'internet la
part d'ab les partis qu'ils jouent elles
seront en direct
il y avait eu une condition comme ça en
1970 donc il ya cinquante ans qu'ils
peuvent c'était l'urss que le reste du
monde
ça a joué par télégramme non je n'aime
pas consensuels penser qu'un oui c'est
bien la radio je sais plus c'était la
radio au télégramme
mais eux ils des trucs qui sont jeux en
réelles ou sinon à belgrade et et pour
le coup en fait pour des gens enfin
normaux qui voudraient troquant ses
parties battait pas la date avait rien
qui doit attendre que des magazines la
publie s'asseoir dans délire qu'une
parution savez si moi je sais pas
content tu dois attendre pour et parfois
il y avait des parties qui dit qu' paris
sait jamais exactement
et du coup tout avec beaucoup moins
d'informations ça va être beaucoup moins
vite
il bat sa chambre est en fait tu pouvais
rejouer plus ou moins la même chose
plusieurs fois sans mesure soit trop
près tu avais une idée qu'il faut la
répéter
maintenant tu le fais une fois tout le
monde au courant tout le monde analyse
et ils te mettent là martin dessus pour
bosser et c'est très différent pour ça
très concrètement les partis qui sont
joués il se peut et c'est même probable
qu'ils aient des seconds en deux joueurs
qui ne sont pas présents dans le tournoi
qu'ils soient déjà en train d'analyser
les parties et qui soit déjà en train de
faire tourner les ordinateurs pour se
dire s'il rejoue telle variante est ce
que qu'est-ce qu'il faudra qu'on fasse
eh ben c'est ça c'est à dire que demain
demain déjà ils seront prêts pour
rejouer le même truc ou contre même si
un jour je compte maxime était noir
il fallait préparer cette vente de
l'anim blocage de l'accès aux dames cédé
au début et ce gros conflit sans seins
c'est sa stature c'est vrai que ça a
changé beaucoup de choses et alors ça
c'est un autre charme c'est c'est
différent des échecs à l'ancienne mais
ça a son charme aussi c'est un peu comme
un comme quand même régler une formule 1
voit là c'est très concret maintenant
c'est ça avant tu pouvais l'appeler
plusieurs fois tu veux plus jouer des
choses tratégie cartes et petits plans
savoir à compromettre les pièces la
saisit la moindre air ne va pas pardonné
son fameux malheureusement ou
heureusement ça m'est donc maxime qui a
mis sa tour en h4 pour venir
latéralement attaqué deux fous des
quatre est bloqué aussi le pion et
peut-être venir un jour sur f4 pour
aller chercher la case f5 éventuellement
qui pourrait être intéressante et son
adversaire chinois qui a joué roigé
cette quasi immédiatement à ses attaques
le choc de besoin on avait dit qu'on ne
veut pas le prendre à l'époque parce
qu'il y avait cette double attaque avec
les chèques étaient annoncés vite mais
s'il ya plus droit n'est plus doublettes
à tous maxime qui met la tour en a eu
quatre
alors qui veut chasser la dame et
essayer peut-être de mettre en danger ce
fou ouais
adam de plusieurs cases perdues dame c5
puis à 2005 mais aussi pour jeu sur le
clouage à dire que l'on lâche la défense
du fou mais c'est une défense tactique
on va dire entre guillemets puisque la
tour serait immobilisé par ce proche
alors les joueurs qui ont peur de tam f5
peut-être ici mais ba s'était autant
fait là il ya quand même le point de vue
tout à sauver et en tant que voilà c'est
ça qu'on disait si défense tactique donc
un nom des gens pas l'fou directement
mais il trouve qu'il est improbable
parce qu'il ya un problème
donc là c'est visible c'est la dame qui
sont tout de suite mais est maintenant
il ya ça qui masse et si on venait à
bouger le fou on se prendrait le nom v2
voilà j'ai donc plus que flou il tend
plus en prison mais oui n'ayons donc
d'aller à 5 coups dangereux coup
dangereux
je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il ya max il en
tête dessus tête ufferte am2 et huawei
temps chronos est on prend des quatre
comme ça et à vrai dire cette variante
rage
ça va nous rappeler la première partie
de maxime c'était à refaire un pion de
plus pour les noirs mais il a le tour
que va se tenir
qui se tient une journée sympa mais mais
un peu dommage finalement de se
retrouver sur la défensive alors qu'on
espérait mettre un petit peu la pression
sur l'adversaire
ouais mais on parlait de maxime qui a
été plus plus dangereux avec eux quatre
ils rejouent des quatre et c'est vrai
que ça se passe pas forcément bien bon
ben c'est pas la cata mais c'est juste
que ça risque de devis tendre vers cette
position là où la voir se battre pour
faire mieux lors c'est se battre ça
reste un grand ouf ça on n'en sait pas
trop dur mais on aura abandonné toute
idée de s'imposer voix max linder à la
caméra qui n'a pas l'air d'être de faire
la tête des grands jours là on n'est pas
inquiet non plus mais ça se voit qu'il
n'est pas très heureux de ce qu'il a
obtenu 10 min qui joue d'un rêve 5
justement dont qui crée ce pot avant on
parlait est là prête à me 2 c'est vrai
que la position pourrait vite allez donc
sur le faire cette finale au tour qui
est quand même assez facilement nul à
civaux femmes
oui surtout que la tour blanche très
bien placées contre calais entre les
deux pions qui défendra son propre qui
ont donc été apte à créer le pion à
leurs doubles emplois de la tour ce qui
est toujours très bien et qui pacifie
rage et une fois de plus la tour adverse
à la défense mais on sait toujours pas
le credoc est pacifiée voilà fassi fihri
patient il a fait d'amd de alors ça peut
être exactement la même chose hein les
gars après d'un problème de ça ne change
absolument rien c'est la même variante
est à mon avis c'est ce qu'on va voir
sur l'échiquier voilà c'est fait s'est
joué d'un croiseur juste là il a
peut-être le choix je vais foot et 5
aussi ça qu'elle est plus simple salut
douar je n'échangerais main ne plus de
trucs moi aussi mais bon les deux
doivent marcher c'est une question de
goût fab
on dit souvent donc final le jeu
proposés doivent en général tiré vers un
nul même s'il ya plein d'exception fait
attention mais s'il reste des pièces
c'est pas si simple
une tour c'est déjà pour foutu peut en
faire des choses pour pour bien montrer
un set cette position là semble quand
même assez facile parce que la tour
c'est vrai qu'elle défend le pion à la
taca la fusion préférentiels on va
pouvoir peut-être la montée jusqu'en à 5
pour qu'elle ait une super position
préférentielle où elle défend l attaque
et l attaque et ce genre de position
j'ai envie de te dire sais c'est nul
assez triviale normalement faut pas trop
se tromper après mais cirque les noirs
on a du mal à voir comment il compte
améliorer leur position sinon à quand le
5ème ça qui compte
mais baston plus fort est valorisé en
créer un plan passe et essayer de
l'amener à promotion un jour parce que
donc le jeu change sur la phase où on en
est dans l'ouverture pour se développer
à bléneau pièces en jeu le milieu de jeu
c'est plus un peu peut-être un jeu
d'attaqué ces deux matières adverse mais
dans les finales on n'a plus beaucoup de
matériel pour le matin on a plus qu'une
tour longtemps tout seul
difficilement 21 20 donc le rock pas
devient partie prenante du combat et ils
soient souvent ces rois monte au combat
et ça devient un jeu plus de promotions
ou essayez donc de rendre un de ses
pions car dame l'a mené jusqu'au bout
pour le transformer et blessures sur
narbonne hommes de plus à la fin on
pourra jouer pour mater l'adversaire
mais là ça c'est difficile parce que
vous voyez les pions f5 h5 qui sont
complètement bloqués par le duo pions
que j'ai trois points 4 la tour qui peut
pas vraiment venir faire quoi que ce
soit parce que sinon le pion à sède
tomberez et du coup ce serait même les
blancs qui ont un pion à qui pourrait
filer bon c'est quand même nul mais
j'appelle à les blancs et leurs contre
le et et on voit mal comment les noirs
peuvent mettre la moindre pression ici
non surement ils peuvent pas un patron
c'est juste on peut pas progresser
c'est il ya des fois où ça va suffire
largement dans un grand club mais là en
l'occurrence les blancs ont très bien
placé leur tour ça c'est eux
c'est important un signal elle serait
ailleurs sa tête pas aussi simple mais
la belle n'empêche les noirs d'avancé a
le droit et même dans la tacc l'option
mail dont un maximum en fait il va rien
faire il va juste bouger son endroit un
peu diva et bien autour de son pion donc
comme il veut soit sur le colza
chaussures à colonnettes et non ça va il
a l'air heureux maximin du coût
inférieur tu vas attendre que ça conclut
vraiment ici voilà on peut juste faire
un petit tour à pied donc garde pour le
moins à la caméra sur le joueur français
histoire de voir s'il ya une conclusion
le garde en dessous de nous on est alors
dans cette position leeuwen aronian oui
écoute c'est encore une finale deux
tours avec fous de couleurs opposées
décidément c'est le thème du match et là
encore ça semble ça semble quand même
aller pour les vols ça devrait aller
mais je dois faire attention si un jour
les noirs ce fonds du tour h6 alors pour
l'instant ça très bien le fou ou trois
gardes la case donc on se fait pas trop
attaquer autour de nous mais faut
reprendre un petit peu vigilants avec
les noirs mais je pense qu'alors peut
vraiment solidifier un monde autre âge 6
fuji 5 comme ça bientôt blindés ça
serait bien ce projet s'inscrit là son
socle on le défend avec le pion à se
défendre mais à l'autre ça bloque
complètement les velléités blanche sur
cette aile et ils savent très bien
voilà en plus ce wiki qui rentre dans
une stratégie des changes
donc il semble fable que cette partie va
elle aussi aller vers la lune petit à
petit guy anish giri aguerris qui jouent
contre contre yun junghee a hélas encore
une position quand même on le sert et
que ses joueurs chinois sont très
solides on vous le disait en début de
match est assez dur de passer là c'est
complètement symétrique les mêmes pièces
sur l'échiquier
bon il peut encore y avoir des pièges ou
je vois le cracker mais la position est
très symétriques très équilibré et
semble se diriger vers là nul est donc
tout pourrait se jouer sur sur mal à
jouer john avec l'élan contre nana
dernier avec les noirs et évidemment
c'est un peu plus animé un seynois que
c'est partout où il ya plus de pièces il
ya pas de symétrie et je dois dire
j'aime bien même alors est ce que tu
veux qu'on ce focus un petit peu sur
cette partie fabien ben je pense à la
plus intéressante en fait ça va sûrement
ce jeu là sinon je te propose une
je veux qu'on fasse donc tu veux je te
laisse un petit peu meublé pendant que
je fais le changement de caméra mais
alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
position donc on voit qu'il ya égalité
matérielle les deux camps on scipion
chacun de fou pour les cavaliers les
blancs ces deux cavaliers un fou mais
cavaliers fou c'est à peu près la même
valeur juste les blancs ont bien pris
l'espace au centre donc une belle
liberté de manoeuvre et il ya la colonne
j'ai donc c'est là où il ya les rois qui
est complètement ouverte donc c'est un
peu qui va arriver à s'engouffrer sur
cette colle en premier pour aller
menacer le droit de l'ars et geslin song
avec les blancs ça risque d'être un peu
plus facile grâce à justement cet espace
central qui doit maintenant que je vous
disais cette liberté de manoeuvre et on
va pouvoir coulisses et donc d'un côté
de l'autre et ça me semble donc un peu
dangereux voilà c'est mon analyse sur la
position
alors après reste à le mettre en
pratique comme il ya encore beaucoup de
questions chic et on peut vite se
trouver faire une gaffe et que ça tombe
dans un sens ou dans l'autre mais alors
je lâche une info maxime a fait nul hein
c'est officiel ok bon on s'en doutait un
peu du bien ben écoute c'est pas en soi
c'est un déshonorant enfin c'était quand
même nouveau 3 mondial mais on n'a rien
obtenu avec les mains et donc on est on
est de retour fab avec nana nizet donc
avec les pièces noires donc quand tu le
disais en difficulté mais rien n'est
fait la position encore très complexes
c'est ça c'est ça il ya eu nul aussi
chez les van aronian et oui donc deux
nuls souligné il ne reste plus que deux
joueurs guiry qui va sûrement faire une
station tout se jouait sur cet échiquier
la violence y est l'arrêt mais voilà
donc l'objet d'agen sont que les blancs
ils vont plus facilement venir
s'engouffrer par la colonne g et mehr
liberté de manoeuvre pour leur pièce
peut être avancer même les pions encore
un peu plus haut un jour et c'est pas si
je vais à clément vainqueur c'est assez
restreint dans notre jeu il ya un autre
coup qui peut arriver c'est du kallisté
cinq localités trois là qui pourrait
venir les geeks ou près la liaison dame
qui a validé quatre ans passés aussi
sale fans principales démarches et sky
beckham serait court et on coupait du
reste et il n'y a pas de caisse de
retraite si elle pouvait jouer tour à 4
mai à tours 1 4 ça va ça va menacer
maintenant en fait elle vient jouer
là-bas les trois donc maintenant tour à
4 serait une menace c'est ça c'est dans
la même veine que le calice et sont
incomplètes ces deux d'attaquer cette
pièce dont j'avais raison 4 c'est pas
plus mauvaise lequel c'est simple c'est
la même chose c'est de l'attaqué ce
qu'avaient indiqué un peu tout seul
les noms auraient adoré pouvoir à 5
eux-mêmes plutôt jeu parce que j'en ai
l'opportunité mais pas laisser le pion
blanc et venir mais m eux mêmes options
très toit de la ferme mais dommage on
sent le peut-être que québec a un peu
aventureux c'est ça la ne fallait pas le
faire c'est logique si tard elle met là
il tue le plein est-ce que ligne super
compétition de gaz qui veut plus être
attaqué il ya plus de pions blancs
comptent attaquer et tu joues de concert
avec tous fous etc
mais si jamais tu le mets là mais qui
dit qu'il n'a pas la solidité d'obtenir
l'amm et regarde comme elle aime bien
jouer à fait car je te contrôler en et
gallas de rebond et je peins pas
question au passage tu défends ton cul
ans qui est hyper logique
maintenant je te fais à cinq je t'enlève
ton sobre et je prépare qu as tu reviens
vers des cinq je te fais quatre jeux de
chasse je prends le centre donc dames 7
est hyper logique un maintenant je te
fais f4 je te bloque ton petit on peut
très logique tu joues gesac bon j'aime
bien le coup en soi découvrez votre acte
iv quoi moi mais eux quatre et je te
bloque complètement fait c'est en
quelques coups là la joueuse chinoise a
vraiment dominé m ouais c'est très
progressif et très logique tout ce
qu'elle fait et ça tient bien ensemble
en plus et j'ai bien peur pour ce
cavalier - là bas un peu tout seul à se
faire encercler ouais alors surtout à 4
j'ai l'impression qu'elle veut pour le
moment je vais tourner les 8 et essayer
de chercher du contre jeu sur le roi
adverse pour qu'on ait qaïda bon après
ce que ça fait tellement mais aussi
peut-être 3 4 elle peut faire un tour
seulement voulu cabine faire ces 5 et
s'adonne à castétis bah c'est pas
terrible hein c'est super comme un pion
l'histoire mais bon c'est le jeu par un
tueur bien qu à belle île et un bfr
allez je pensais qu'elle cherchait une
contre attaque et ça fonctionne dans un
second temps mais peut-être qu'en fait
les blancs peut jouer qu'à laisser 5
pour le coup vraiment permis de
cavaliers en bi 4 et pas laisser ce test
est à l'honneur alors jailli et danger
huit dames 1 il faut prendre quatre
ouais bon bah il faut tenter ça en fait
c'est un peu en désespoir de cause c'est
sûrement ça ne mange pas du tout mais
complique un peu la vie des blancs tu tu
as fait bien peu leur défense autour du
roi tc2 fait objectivement c'est sûr
c'est pas trop marché s'est complètement
foutu mais en plus ce que le dernier un
deuxième problème c'est que les blancs
pourraient ne pas prendre ce qu'a dit si
vite et de faire un run
enfin quel ses cinq tours j'ai vite
franchi alors on l'a tous même pas où on
prend le 4 et le cab et où souvent il va
pas sans mal et ça c'est un truc
important sur échec des fossiles si vous
en mourrez une pièce et qu'elle peut pas
partir bas dans un coup il pourra partir
non plus
pas sans voile est donc certain de se
presser et je crois que malheureusement
notre joueuse européenne perd donc la
championne du monde
ighirri s'est fait enfermé sa tour tous
les genres européens seront fermées
leurs pieds de la tour la boîte où seuls
aventureuse va sur le même sort que le
cavalier de dos dames 1 alors après
peut-être que oui rien que ça parce
qu'il a compris que damas était plus qu
ils quittent ont de grandes attentes de
compliqué mais bon ça ne donne rien
après je pense que c'est un peu tôt dans
tous les cas pauline parce que ici avec
les noirs à vrai dire
nana elle est perdante comme tu nous l'a
expliqué aux femmes mais il faut quand
même dire que c'est pas fini et qu'il
peut y avoir encore des petits des
petites choses il souffre pas déjà faut
que les blancs trop encore beaucoup pour
l'instant elle joue parfaitement donc ya
pas dans quel s'arrête encore août mais
j'aime à l'abri
oui wind on n'est jamais à l'abri de
rien mary j blidge dire que tenter le
holy night c'est encore un poil tort à
mon avis pour les blancs surtout que
c'est une position tu pourra le faire
plus tard non mais je pense que grille
juste craquer tout seul ça arrive aussi
un même aux meilleurs mais tu vois des
machines ce choix de kasparov finalement
se retourne est-ce qu'on va pas remettre
le coach mairie arrête on fera les
bilans à la fin fallait faire très très
tôt quand même tu as perdu un match que
j'irai tout voulons plus te voir
on fait bien les visages qui comme ce
que fait dès qu'ils ont très intéressant
tu me mets titulaire ou pas si tu es tu
sélectionnes mais alors qui va
travailler commentaire chez pas gary
haifa va qu'augmenter pas bah oui je
sois très intéressant de fabien est visé
ce qui encombre qui a titularisé ce
joueur je n'y avais pas pensé quoi je
n'avais pas bien d'observer pendant le
mercato l'entraîneur de renom mais du
coup que je sais pas ce qu'ils ont
appelé chimay
la plupart des hommes seront de toute
façon même est ce que votre bonne
solution ne tue pas la bonne option car
c'est plus dur quand tu as trop de
bonnes options restant n'a qu'une tu vas
faire sans la trouver
t'as pas le choix tu as trop bonne
option vas tu ça peut ça peut mener à
l'erreur alors que je vois sur un petit
écran de contrôle que maxime il regarde
il regarde les parties j'atteins aille
alors réfléchi on va jeter un oeil côté
anish giri quand même est-ce que cette
tour est non juste te dire un peu ce qui
se passe c'est railleur dans le match du
4 1 secondes déjà eu deux restent actifs
s'ajoutent partout sauf sur un échiquier
du match reste du monde
un d eux nul entre radja loi fait
viciana c'est fou en fait cette équipe
de chine c'est vraiment une armada
ils sont ils sont très très forts ils
sont forts ils sont solides ils sont
durs à battre est déjà dans les
olympiades cessa leurs tricks en fait tu
sais pas où tu fais un point contre donc
au pire ils perdent pas et font deux
doigts sont là je ne dort jamais et puis
bandé que film peter bale sont là un
filon cette force en fait par équipe est
solide c'est plutôt un point positif
tu fais craquer les autres mentalement
ou quoi c'est vraiment des matches il un
son très fort de tomber les pois c'est
en leur envoyant des lauriers tout le
temps comme ça j'espère bien je sens
maxime complètement et que rien je le
vois toujours à la can d'arbitrage l'air
d'être écuries ray mais bon c'est vrai
que quand tu vois ton équipe comme ça
qu'ils disent est on voit mal le match
depuis dix minutes c'est fini oui là
c'est un petit peu comme si on était
menés à
deux gardes je foutais un peu sa voie
après c'est pas le même ratio de temps
en tête au tennis tu sais pas un tueur
de perdre un set zéro et a pris un break
il ya 6 1 6 1 6 1 2 0 quoi on te dis bon
clavier mais bon à la fac a laissé cinq
ans plus le coût qui semblait le plus
pénible parce que comme on l'a dit sa
coupe la défense de la tam 7 avec son
cavalier en b 4 qui est complètement
isolée du reste pas de ces pièces waskie
smar d'à côté et le gall est tout seul
là bas et ce n'est pas possible
grosse géométrie chez les blancs et
n'avait pas hésité avec des cabanes ic2
on lie à leroy camion a fuité el cheikh
a voulu tenter été prises des caprices
des caprices des caprices des cas qui
essaient de fourchette ça marcherait
n'ont aucune variante ya le carélien qui
couvre bien plus même l'un jours-ci et
blanc sont attaqués et aura toujours des
thèmes de défense avec tour à trois
étudiants à colmater en deux groupes
ouais et on fout et colmatée par le
cavalier oui si c'est lui je vois même
pas un scénario dans laquelle ça peut
bien tourné pour faudra vraiment
beaucoup de beaucoup dé rabat par des
blancs à tanger les trois chalets ça
rien et c'est même pas sûr le 4 juin
portée à une championne du monde là bas
non mais bien sûr mais je joue vraiment
bien mais bon tout ça mais tu imagines
la qualité du quatrième échiquier
chinois tu fais sortir boulifa numéro un
mondial et tu fais rentrer de jouer à
une jounée tu as peut-être même renforcé
son équipe face et c'est quand même très
qualitatif 1 mais je pense que le choix
de kasparov quand même de mettre sa
guise et est pas idiot noms du poker pas
on sait pas trop ce sont 6 cia n'a fait
mieux prête son toit facile de parler
après quand tu vois le résultat des
parties où il fallait faire ça c'est
l'avant qui monte
on a quand même le droit de columbia
rien mais bon il fallait savoir nous
nous sachions nous aurions su ouais
c'est difficile pour l'équipe européenne
faudra dès demain se reprendre parce que
ouais bon beaucoup face tirs réels
terrestres qui compte ce sont les
dialogues match par la chine il ya un
désordre ans et d'équipements à ce
tournoi très difficile nuls contre les
russes mais donc s'asseoir et prendre
des points
je sais pas trop lors des matches 2-1
mais en tout cas il ya quand même des
grosses équipes à avoir affronté il y
aura les usa et rollin et reste du monde
s'est pas fait non plus et voici équipes
les plus faibles c'est pas tout qu'il
ira contre n'y aura pas de matches
faciles ratés relancer le groupe d'art
tout ce qui arrive est 4 fois vraiment
vraiment fermé on répète ainsi la
joueuse géorgienne et est aussi mal
c'est parce que ce cavalier n'a plus de
case je vais refaire des flèches pour
montrer que toutes les cases du cavalier
toutes les cases possibles sont
contrôlés par une par une pièce adverse
nombre d'autres se passerait il se
ferait manger ou boire plus propres
pions ouais et y a personne qui peut
venir le sauver toute son armée et à est
coupé de sa défense le cavalier c5 qui
construit la connexion de la dame vers
le cavalier et des pions qui peuvent pas
avancer
ok et les noirs qui vont tout perdre ce
qui allait alors du coup quand c'est
comme ça
de toute façon c'est très mal parti il
faut faire un peu aux lignes de l'autre
côté mais mais même ça c'est pas facile
à faire les plans sanctions envers
solide
non mais c'est ok t'es foutu voilà c'est
dur et on nous propose pions v6 alors
qu'ils ont baissé si on prend b6 ya 25
tours prend 1,5 et en fait oui on se
fait la place font cavalier mais en fait
c'est encore le cas ce qui fait de
contrôler pour la paix ça démarre donc
au final dans l'histoire on aura tenté
de sauver le cavalier on aura juste
quand même car du cavalier et encore
deux options mais c'est rare d'avoir une
telle une telle géométrie
osez chacun d'avoir un camp qui contrôle
aussi bien erraient le roi et la halle
dame et le centre parce que le centre
elle le tient elle tient à l dame hélène
roy à la tient lé pa moin bien aller
droit non plus en réalité c'est rare
quand même aux échecs d'avoir une telle
main sur l'échiquier main de fer il y
avait du coup cette catastrophe à dos
webb a peut-être pas peur il devrait
mais au mieux il fera il fera partie
nulle en sauvant ce à quoi me ils
menacent pas digne en tout cas non
écoute on va rester un peu sur nana ce
qu'elle peut tenter faut trop une idée
faut tenter quelque chose on ne propose
pas s'être carrier des 5 euros - au
moins prendre un pur on l'histoire bien
sûr c'est mieux que rien mais bon c'est
pas c'est parce qu'on n'a même pas d'
attaque les bleus ont fait un truc comme
qui a veillé à 3 on va créer une tour en
vain le cas des tonnes de cadeaux centre
et puis voilà été hissé sa campus qui
est monstrueux c'est ça qui est dur en
fait c'est qu'on n'a même pas une once
de contre eux je sais ce que ce que dana
doit chercher au moins de pouvoir mettre
un petit danger un petit peu quelque
chose j'étais petite banane essaie de
faire glisser adversaires mais bon rien
on n'arrive pas à trouver non plus je
crois qu'ils se sont forgés 4 pour
maintenir 6-4 en f4 oui mais non mais
c'est donc à une autre option pour
gagner un tour je pense dans tous les
cas elles varient va gagner un pion pro
kevin mais c'est difficile c'est rare ce
genre de match quand même qui sont
autant à sens unique sur un cas très
chic et joueur qui tourne aussi vite
généralement il peut y avoir une
position comme ça perdante est sûre sur
l'échiquier restant l'autre ça peut être
un petit peu habite aussi serré qui
minerait la c
c'est vraiment à sens unique c'est
vraiment rare c'est vrai je m'achetais
vite vite tourner dans le sens de
l'équipe de chine nous propose dames
c'est cette peut-être voit la même chose
à prendre mais qu'après 4 mais au fait
au final
bon déjà souvent je mets les normes
n'ont même pas de menace ce terrifiant
donc presque wasp a rien à faire même si
ton corps n'a reculé devant les filets
ben ça suffit pas et c'est très mauvais
signe un transfert en date deux cours
gratuits et on peut vraiment faire alors
la joue et qui a dessiné ce cas la prise
a ajouté des cinq sûrement aux cavaliers
avaient troqué vaio cinq tours et c'est
que ces terrains 5 ça va arriver pour
nana ça va être mission impossible
voilà donc ce équipe de chine vraiment
forte
ils sont papier il par ses très forts de
base mais maintenant qu'on les voit à
l'oeuvre
il ya du lourd ben ils font part a déjà
deux matches s'ils font deux matches
deux victoires dès le premier jour ils
ont gagné 3 le premier match c'est ça en
plus ben là il peut faire pareil
s'ils font 2 3 dès la première journée
non seulement ils vont prendre la tête
ils vont prendre le goal avérage
et ils vont être très dures à les
déboulonner à ça mais bon droit l'once
d'une semaine six jours non mais qui au
final de toute façon alors côté guiry à
80 il rôde autour du roi
c'est ce qui peut c'est possible qu'il
prenne cette décision
en fait en disant bon bah voilà j'ai
livé donc avec jean aurait pas de
problème avec moi j'ai quand même un
pion plus dans cette finale de dames au
pire je n'irai pas mais je parle jamais
donc vu le score vue qui tu vois ta
collègues qu'elle va gagner
dès que ça ces stratégies de match
toujours à un tournant et du diable
serait tout seul tu voudrais quand même
l'emporter dans cette position est
claire
donc tu pourrais prendre table d'hôte
risque là en fait si tu sais que toute
façon nul ça équivaut à migné battait
pptp pouze vous êtes vous exactement
tp pouzac avec les noirs aucun risque
mais quelle qu'elles maîtrisent un
qu'elle maîtrise c'est fantastique
qu'elle sollicitait jamais une erreur
c'est ça qui est vous aussi un pack
jamais faut jamais dire jamais mais très
peu d'erreurs de la part de ses joueurs
chinois n'ont n'a pas vu un seul maillot
de bain à une stabilité à une stabilité
impressionnante et cavalières 3 et
parvenir on s'inquiète beaucoup de
qualité en tout cas chez ses joueurs
est ce que quelqu'un peut faire un
résumé vingt deux nuls rapide de maxime
et et les vols aux deux premiers
échiquiers et les deux autres joueurs en
difficulté donc là nous c'est le chip
europe
c'est l'âge aux calendres nana zzani
zeng ebome à une caisse de man en fait
ma position c'est ça le problème
on va que les blancs trois pièces
légères de cavaye un fou les marmots que
de chou donc ça se passe mal et anish
giri troisième joueur ou nous contrôler
mais chic et qui a les blancs qui donc
dans cette finale où on a plus que roi
dame et quelques options chacun mais
laure martin plüss
comptez puis déjà et lens il veut le
faire nul de juste faire échec échec
échec
et là il ya minimoy il peut faire ça en
plus il peut laisser fier du temps à la
pendule et l'annoncent comme ça il y
aura toujours des échecs perpétuel ou
quoi est mal et blanc c'est les blancs
qui veulent faire du ici c'est oui il va
rester un aspect donc pas tout ça c'est
avec lena dürr ni peut attendre un peu
giraud prg sur ma nuque et en plus il
joue même pas ce pleutre pour faire
d'elle tout de suite il a défendu son
pion l'abordage 7 et une tête passait le
roi avancer petit à petit il faire de
son mieux pour eux s'ils gagnent
vraiment qu'on reste sur à l'autre
partie c'est la seule chance c'est qu'il
ya une crise il était blanc ça peut
arriver on va te la pression la plus
gagnante des deux mers c'est celle là où
il ya le plus de pièces donc
potentiellement on sait pas oui furent
vu ça elle doit gagner entre guillemets
l'autre faire un nul c'est c'est
vraiment élémentaire dans l'autre
position n'a gagné ça peut ça peut
toujours est une autre question
cavalier avec trois nuls qui veut
revenir vers le 5
on l'a dit la tour qui veut venir en
vain doublé sur la colonne ya un pion 17
qui peut être en prise à un moment donné
aussi on ne va pas négliger le cavalier
qui contrôle la casse de cas donc il ya
même pas d'idées à base de foule 4 il
semble vraiment que les plantes contrôle
absolument tout l'échiquier et les noirs
n'ont quasiment pas de casque pour
s'exprimer et c'est pour ça que annie
g'sell n'arrive même pas à jouer des
coups vite pour mettre la pression sur
la pendule ou quoi parce que les coûts
sont durs à trouver en fait quoi que tu
joues ça va pas ça quand tu as que des
eaux etc où c'est possible
jean des accus comptes a que des bons
coups c'est da silva sont bien choisir
mes encore sa gamme comme ça en fait et
des primes edouard nabe est encore plus
déprimé et là et puis tout le temps donc
tu sais plus quoi faire
c'est pas facile ça paraît elle a de
moins en moins de temps à la caméra on
est pas super expressive réfléchit bien
fait quand même pas la tête des grands
jours un peu peu dubitative ouais à
l'efo joint un coup à jouer vite et bien
ça peut être le conseil qu'on peut lui
donner ça c'est un bon conseil mais là
je voulais bien c'est dur mais jouer
vite c'est possible je vais vite c'est
possible au moins je vois un coup et
peut-être un conseil si je vois un coup
joué une partie ton franc g20 - il
envoie quelque chose ouais bon soir
l'échec
j'adore avec l'autre tour j'adore venir
mais s'ils avaient pas le cavalier c'est
ça que je vais faire les sales président
fait changer mais donc ces codes à ce
rythme on n'a pas grand chose un peu
moins elle elle elle prend sa chance
mais bon là une tour de moins nette
j'ai essayé de prendre des 4 et
peut-être poussé deux pions et ma foi
c'est via moins de matériel encore que
tout à l'heure c'est probablement
objectivement pire mais d'un autre côté
au moins tu tu crées une menace d'un
projet pour les fêtes
mais je crois que c'est dû retrouver un
couple aimant bien tour des deux hommes
g3 plus que tu revenir de trept l'autre
ah oui non mais c'est tellement de coups
ouais mais très bien aussi dj trance tu
les changes et les dames où tour à 20
tours à b1 tu défends tout un mois il ya
trop de coups bas
les blousons ya pas il n'ya pas il ya
trop de contrôle c c'est vraiment une
excellente partie de la jeune chinoise
on le répète mais c'est rare d'avoir des
partis tout a tellement dominé
stratégiquement en milieu de jeu que que
ta position est juste écrasante exact
exact c'est exact mais la boîte bien mal
parti de l'autre côté on se met un peu à
espérer non pas du tout il y aura des
cela venait de tuer le suspense on peut
enfin ouais mais je peux pas faire et
les positions qu'on a là est-ce qu'on
peut essayer roitg 3 et damages quatre
matches on peut rêver de ça il ya des
chances que l'adversaire le voir et donc
les normes menace qui échangent des
dames larache 4 qui rentrait ensuite
finale d'options et les finales depuis
avec un pion de plus sont la plupart du
temps gagnante c'est ça en fait vous
avez un ton plus moyen de pièces sur
l'échiquier plus aux pions prendre la
valeur parce que oui et puis qui
existent on va dire et ils n'ont pu vous
rapprocher de la victoire pas par simple
curiosité dans les autres matches 1 1
partout entre l'inde et le reste du
monde et dans le match russie usa
les américains ont pris le dessus avec
une victoire pour le moment de caruana
sur artemiev mais on y reviendra peut
être un petit peu plus tard mais les
américains alors mon friable c'est
peut-être un échiquier donc si leur jose
irina crush tient le coup contre d'un
match qui n'a évidemment ni ils sont
bien dans match parce qu'ils sont assez
monstrueux soit trop prolifique et et
les plus forts sur les trois premières
le truc c'est que ballan voilà china
great joué john qui sort une partie
extraordinaire
il est des états unis ils ont pas c'est
équivalent tu te fais une partie quand
elle commence à jouer à steve owen
pourrait jouer sur les premiers
échiquiers n'y aurait pas de problème
mais je la croise chaque année à hauteur
de gibraltar
ton mari way qui a beaucoup de joueuses
et pas mal de meilleur joueur au monde
aussi quoi et gardent cinq dames aller
d'amour à f2 et un match banal avoir un
petit triangle les changer d'âme et
ouais je profite surtout aux jeunes bien
même elle joue souvent les premiers
rôles a pas de la gagner le tournoi mais
elle est dans les 20 premiers au
classement quoi c'est pas rien du tout
dans un tel tournoi
manon dubois jun avec céline super
joueuse et la honda mende à mach 4
salles et abandon donc le score
le score wallemme et trois matches
quatre jolies manoeuvres qui force les
changes des dames et abandon d'aniche
diri donc il remplace duda et qui perd
d'entrée
c'est triste bon ben là c'est juste joué
par inertie un peu ce qu'elle fait
maintenant même si aucune chance mais
ouais bah écoute les chinois est mort
impressionné en tout cas plus encore que
ce que je pensais avant elle s'inscrira
elle veut faire dame 3-6 4-6 matt
fougères c'est pour défendre à m6 dont
il va faire bouger 5 peut-être mais la
juste apprendre le fouet ans et une
tournette de plus ça devrait marquer de
points rapidement
nana qui s'accroche quand même à elle
mérite de rabot toute façon jamais gagné
partir d'un bandeau nan mais là pour le
coup je crois que le donjon voit pas les
gagner donc c'est difficile pour maximin
qui en chef d' été faites ces derniers
jours bon au moins lui individuellement
nunchuk mais bon oui avec les blancs il
n'a pas ne pas poser de problème à la
dire ça écoute de deux parties 2 nuls 1
finalement
contepomi architecture l'avenir des murs
et de la matière mais l'autriche qui
nous dit qu'un sport doit rendre des
comptes ce soir je crois bien
je crois que les murs ont tremblé
d'investia ouais là l'ordinateur affiche
m'attend cette poussée pour te dire et
c'est vrai que la manoeuvre dame j'ai
trois dames g8 fait mal et abandon de
nana donc match expéditif fab et on va
aller suivre du coup je te propose